[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right in my check my chat what's
going on
it is the lord's day
[Music]
what's going on talk to me talk to me
just filing into the room get a seat
congregation in the lord's day you know
i'm saying make sure you pull up up
front
[Laughter]
okay yeah thank you shane i'm gonna turn
myself up i see my level still look a
little low
a little low all right it's a terrible
cell up just a little bit yeah i know i
get loud so i try to keep myself a
little bit
under control don't get everybody in
here phil brown what's going on dizzy
what's up
you know what i mean let's see we got
rrd
what's thank you sir thank you so much
appreciate it
that is the lord of time stamps my mans
you know what's in it
you played up playing okay playing that
new raid all right okay
boston you know what's up no doubt thank
you no man thank you thank you
it's all good it's all good i'll be
watching on the hot all we got the
legends in here today we got log that
over here today
good thing i wore my long neck shirt
so look man we gonna get kmac up in a
building home attic i have not
heard from so let's see what's going to
solve i have not heard from so we'll see
how this gonna go this morning because
it might be just calling it a guest
dead oh what's going on season again
happy anniversary season gaming
salute to them brothers you already know
all right bosnian
all right i'll check you out i'm gonna
check you out
let's see all right we're gonna get uh
kate meg up in here in a minute
and uh once the law has been king and
everybody pull up i will return
i will talk to you guys in a minute you
already know what it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god all right and
i think just check these levels right
quick yes sir
and we are live welcome to the iron laws
podcast and the lords of gaming.net
episode number 187 that's a song
it is another glorious sunday we're back
at the round table
the lord's date i'm excited about our
special guest and we've got two
major bioware leads leaving the studio
is xbox series x a disappointing console
a series as performance targets to
discuss so we go get right into it
i want to introduce the lord whose
content i was first introduced to by
great friends of the room
lords 108 dragon tv bloody knuckles and
xbox 448.
this lord is more than mega within our
gaming community and his passion for his
craft always shines through
whether it be his outstanding gameplay
respectful debates
and fellow og gaming perspective
introducing the creating host of the
kmega 405 youtube and twitch channels
host of the grg podcast and a panelist
of the next
podcast fellow g1
transformers fan and the lord
reminds us to focus on what's most
important
game is recognizing games he's been
doing it
live from okc and making his
long awaited debut in the realm of the
lord
my man lord cave mega how you doing sir
oh bro i i don't even know how to how to
take that man i mean i know xbox be
giving out some great intros but bro
that's uh that's amazing thank you
so much my mans man it's good to be here
man
i uh it's you know i'm just excited you
know what i'm saying it's uh it's good
it's long overdue people can actually
see now that the beard is
real
[Music]
you've been putting it down for a while
man first of all how you been and what
you've been playing man
oh man uh i've been prepping up and
doing a lot of stuff for grg
um and and and doing stuff like that and
for my uh
twitch channel uh so i haven't really
been playing that much but
it's it's been uh call of duty uh black
ops
i mean
no just turn the ray tracing off people
determine
hey
good to have you in the realm brother we
got a good show going on so we uh
don't have four horsemen i don't know
where one of our horsemen
are shout out to atticky is somewhere in
the bushes i i spoke to him briefly
in this morning but uh if uh someone
could find
cobos please let me know you like we'd
like to look for oh sorry get that right
quick
get that right shout out to game over
brian with the five dollar super chat
lord king thank you from free me for
freeing me from the tcl
shackles i no longer eat off the floor i
now eat head of my table i'm proud over
lg oled 65a
totally respect man total respect i see
you guys out here moving i see you
posting your televisions i see you
stepping your game up
and that's exactly what it is it's about
elevating past you know mediocrity
you know let's just walk past that tcl
let's see it on the floor
let's leave him on the floor let's go to
the back yeah
[Laughter]
you
that was kind of next to me they had a
tcl and they just made them take it
themselves
but you know
it was like um i need help with the tv
you good i can't
what's going on ladies megatron what's
happening everybody
so we got uh we got night music with the
four dollar super chat good morning to
you too
so there's no doubt no doubt brother
yeah we're looking for the young wolf
hopefully we can find him we'll join
in progress but uh we still got our most
technical gaming lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also
the sastradamus the lord of clarity and
patron of the iron bank
my man a little tired this morning lord
sovereign how are we doing yeah
i'm looking i'm looking like i just
crawled out the bushes
11 a.m this is your time what's going on
i was feeling under the weather
yesterday i didn't really get too much
in the way of gaming but i did uh
i was just sitting i was laid up on the
couch watching my beautiful lord of the
rings at 4k
headset on you know dopey atmos poppin
so i you know i was all right but i
wasn't feeling super great but
i did get to game a little bit during
the week because i i was uh one of my
one of my jobs was uh was closed so i
had to go in somewhat but not
not not the entire time so
so i had to give my xbox some love
because uh yeah
i had been i've been neglecting it once
you know miles morales got put to the
side and
and uh an astro he said i gotta get my
xbox on well so i'm playing some
valhalla
[Music]
yeah so why i mean wait a second one
your miles got put to the side in your
asteroid
wait a second i thought they had games
oh hold on all right let's go let's
start let's get to it
let's get to it
so um yeah so playing valhalla i tell
you it's very it feels very different
in a lot of ways it feels just like an
attached game right but in the beginning
it feels very different in terms of the
combat and everything than
than even uh uh odyssey sounds like wait
a minute man this feels a little weird i
don't know if i like this
but i you know playing i'm like maybe 15
hours in now so i've gotten a bunch of
you know i've unlocked a bunch of stuff
and
now the combat feels a little more like
like i expected to even though it does
feel more brutal than it did in
in odyssey like the things you can do
and
i just i decapitated to do with a hammer
like it was crazy
um so i'm enjoying it it really does it
does it has that like
heavy feeling to it especially like i
stopped using
a shield is my secondary weapon i just
use another weapon
and i parry with that and then um so i
have a heavy hammer in my left hand so i
did a move
i held down i got the strong hit and he
jumped and just bashed the dude in the
head and his head came right off
oh wow that's how we're doing it out
here
so yeah i'm enjoying it the game is
gorgeous man
oh that game is pretty and i said i'm
playing dirt like i said dirt what are
you doing
with ray tracing on yourself oh yes sir
oh this is the funny thing too right so
you know like like like y'all like i
have
i have a high power pc that i i barely
use the game though like i just don't i
just came on the consoles more
so you used to that 30 fps so playing it
in 60
playing games in 60 period for a minute
now
yo so you know that assassin's creed
they added the the options now they gave
you the performance mode and they gave
you the fidelity mode right so i said
let me go to fidelity mode to see what
bells and whistles they added
um and i know they dropped it to 30.
dude when i dropped it to 30
it looked like the game was broken
and i don't know if it was perception i
was like is this really broken because
it was so choppy it was it didn't even
feel slow
it felt choppy and i'm like what the
hell is going on here
i said let me throw on red dead because
red dead same thing red dead is dirty
but it never felt choppy very smooth i
throw red dead on
and all i do is just pan the camera
around and to my
eyes it's like
start deceiving my castle brothers got
mad at me
when i i saw that but i came back to 30
destiny i was like oh
no i can't do that it's crazy because
all of us we've been had pcs that could
do this
console gamers but yo oh man so
your eyes really do just get adjusted to
something different
[Laughter]
you notice that there's a perceivable
difference in the smoothness
and especially at 120 hertz it's it's
really drastic
you know and it makes it even harder to
go back to 60 so i try to
refrain from that one but my 120 hertz
is like at uh 1080p anyway so it doesn't
matter so
i'm just like yeah okay real quick you
picked up dirt
i'm surprised yeah no i picked up dirt
because i said you know you know you got
to have your racing game at lunch
um and the thing is your dirt bro
wow which one you did you did which uh
which ball you did
you tried a bunch of well you know yeah
i haven't i haven't upgraded to the 120.
oh so i have the 4k
yeah but the thing about it is like when
that game when it comes to it's crazy
you'll have one in the middle of a race
you will go from
day cycle to night cycle in a lap right
and then within laps 2 you'll get
changes in weather and everything that's
absolutely crazy i mean it's a
straight-up arcade game right but the
it's it's so gorgeous and the the mud
effects
the rain effects the weather effects
like
it's no joke man it really is like i
remember when
when in in the previews i remember ryan
mccaffrey saying like it doesn't look
next-gen and i'm like
i don't think you're playing the patch
version bro because
this this game looks really really
really good in a way in ways that
like again i'm playing for the forza
horizon 4k
now and six i'm playing at 60 rather um
and it's
gorgeous but it doesn't do it's not
but it doesn't set out to do what two
forces
does defense uh dirt
is a controlled track in a controlled
environment in a controlled it's not an
open world
forza has to take into account the
actual world
to actually put that console to the test
but i i saw that
like controlled environment and then
maximum
yeah turn 10 is is probably the
best at when of learning of the the
hardware
from xbox's hardware better than anybody
i mean if you just look and see what
they've done
with uh forza 5 all the way down they
have done
just crazy and then of course what
playground has been doing with horizon
it's been yeah
and i think that's why they're going to
take you know all the rumors that that
horizon 5 comes out before uh the next
forza i think makes sense because
seven didn't really hit the way people
expected it to seven was kind of
it kind of launched with the x didn't it
like it was good it was it launched
um the adaptive triggers and the stuff
like that
it did subtle things that really only
car
enthusiasts would have felt from going
from six to seven
right uh you know going from the it was
just little subtle things
and i think that's that's the biggest
problem right now because i think fidel
fidelity wise we have hit a limit
right so now you have to do subtle
things to bring out
more of what you're trying to see like
frame rate of course
but then they go at it um you know frame
rate of course
but then you want to do stuff like
reflections and you know ray tracing
and then you want to of course make the
crowd
look a little bit more lively so it's
little subtle things that changes the
way
the game looks now opposed to back in
the days like because remember we was
playing sega rally
yeah if you compare dirk to sega rally
[Music]
yeah i'll get these super chats real
quick and then one last thing we got
smitty smith with the two dollar super
chat no more tcl manager specials
and we got briscoe sun with the five
dollar super chat last episode of mando
had the oled gx shining a shout out to
my cxo c10 oversized
just wait a couple of months when i get
to see one and you can
flex exactly exactly okay
the fomo didn't get me there
no you took that tv out the plasma yeah
i took it out i think
that still smacks most things in the
face that that plasma when it came out
was fifteen thousand so um
good morning lord shout out to k mega my
four or five brother
it's sunday so that means fight night i
do yeah i got that
like button chat yeah i got you um
and we got cedric gates with the ten
dollar stupid chat thank you sir please
say something
i think we're caught up yeah real quick
before we move on to king um
i just want to say a big shout out to uh
big bad mo
and um jw is a shield our console
winners have their console
so fantastic nice i am so happy to see
you guys happy with you with your
consoles enjoy
courtesy of the lords courtesy of fat
daddy
fat daddy cat daddy
for helping us with our destiny giveaway
big shout out to him um i believe i
haven't i haven't spoken to him but i i
think
it should have arrived on friday but i
have to get confirmation
yeah you got to win it too you got to
speak to petey behind the scene oh no no
i had that we're going to talk about
that today because
i didn't know if you were going to do it
so yeah yeah yeah you know i i
thought you know what it is that that's
now though didn't didn't get at me
directly on discord so i kind of
didn't notice that the conversation was
about that but i have it in front of me
after i do no doubt lord lord addict man
is the microphone make sure that the the
uh co-host is here
i see him physically in the room but uh
just want to make sure that he
the voice is there it's a spirit here no
yeah
i'm here all right i had to work last
night
okay okay okay it's just yeah then i got
stuck at work so
you got stuck at work no doubt so the
co-host with the co-votes what's going
on man i'll give you
an abbreviated intro i wasn't sure if
you were here or not what
have you been playing anything at all
prior to getting called into work sir
i was playing destiny all week pretty
much um
that's that's that's about that's about
the extent of my week was destiny
and i'm playing attack on titan too yeah
trying that out because it was
how much of a backlock i have and i'm
like i can't justify buying anything i
got to just start playing these games
yeah and i have no clue why my camera is
not working
i i'm going to work on that while you
guys talk all right no doubt no doubt
it's all good you're going to say
working on technical difficulties
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir
oh we're doing fantastic houston stand
up
philadelphia stan uh-oh oh my god last
night if you watched those fights you
saw my boy come back from a car wreck
that killed most people
oh man i've never been so afraid
and so happy to see a fight in my whole
life i was so terrified
in what errol spence jr the truth
will look like in a fight after that
horrific car accident that nobody ever
truly knows what goes on um because i
know danny garcia
philadelphia stand up your champion uh
represented himself
well you know um
there's a difference in boxing there's
levels to this um
and danny danny is a strong champion
danny has fought uh uh sean porter
damn near through a draw for keith
thurman
damn there to a draw he's uh fought zab
judah beat up zab judah he has he has
fought champions
he is beating champions uh he has been
um
the junior welterweight uh unified
champion and he's been a walter weight
champion
so there's no reason to hold your head
down but he was in there with the truth
and from round one the word was spoken
it was true dallas was in the building
oh my god that's a little bit baby
am i back now yeah you're good you're
good yeah you're bad bro bro
out there i guess you'll call it comcast
but out here it's called cox
communications they do that little
internet run chip and i was like
i looked and i was like wait hold on
not today
a couple years ago comcast was looking
into buying them oh well they should
have brought they do
they do own
um so the truth
the truth was definitely shown um it was
some minor things i saw some ring rush
because he's been off for yeah oh she
said my last slide he looked good he
said he was a little rusty she said
well delira in in the ninth round when
he caught the headbutt from
danny garcia i noticed a little
difference and
it was probably was a little
disorienting because for
two rounds he kind of coasted a little
bit
to uh you know like declare his head
yeah you know the 11th round you know
because he asked his corner he said yo
did i lose the round or something
he was like no no no just go out there
and keep doing what you're doing
and in the 11th round you know he went
out there started certain herself and in
the final round he definitely put a
stamp on the fight
um danny garcia was beaten by a
landslide uh
again it is levels to this he is by far
the pound profound champion uh
in boxing right now is not terence
crawford
terence crawford resume is nowhere close
terrace crawford would have gotten
knocked out by danny garcia last night
and i'm gonna be a hundred percent with
you terence you're too light in the butt
you better stay awake
stay away from them yeah but sean porter
is hunting you right now so you got
bigger fish to fry okay
all right um what i've been saying what
i've been playing
oh the game backs up right now cause i
know where this is going yeah yeah yeah
okay okay so get your own so you already
know
king gang pass over here um all that
stuff that y'all talking about your
purchase
i ain't listening to cheese but i was
playing dragon quest
i saw that ea put um for all you nhl
fans yeah they took it back
i did see that yes
um i put in a game called haven okay
excuse me
and haven it has a performance mode
okay boy with fidelity
it felt smooth it felt nice it um
it's a nice little different game that
i'm learning right now
so i just started it i'm probably like
an hour into it
but it's it feels uh fun different
and smooth so i like the direction of
the game and where it's going
but shout out to phil dominus maximus
aurelius spencer
for justifying the fact that i'm never
buying games again
bro control controllers in game pass
controllers in game pass i told you
dudes hold
up man don't spend that money especially
giving 505 that bread because 505 is a
bunch of crooks oh my gosh
control control i'm just worth the
download on gamepad oh yeah
no let me let me tell you the attic is
right is 100
right here we go because i'ma say this
about control
now we was on midweek mix-up oh yeah and
they said yo are you going to go get
because it's eight dollars right now
um you can get the unlimited joint i'm
like oh
and it has the ray tracer yeah well
apparently
the ray tracing don't come until next
year sometimes well it don't come in
that
past version it's not available at all
period
well yeah the ultimate so the ultimate
is the ultimate
it's not out right no no it's not out
yet no it's like that like
yeah i posted the i posted on twitter
uh of how disappointed i was in the fact
that you have to
that you had to pay extra for the dlc
but
the one thing that made me pay for it
was the fact that i didn't have the dlc
because i bought the game day one cause
i'm a big remedy fan so it was like
all right i'll go ahead and i'll chew it
up because it was it was uh
it was 19 bucks and then i've also had
some uh xbox reward cards
so you need a little so there's some
there's a little there's a little stamp
you need to put up there you know what
i'm saying where it needs to be
xbox right now xbox we won't be doing
anything every time you log yeah
you know the crazy thing when it comes
to control
is why he comes out of his way he
changes the conversation
right i know what he's doing because i
was trying to talk about control when it
got changed to that so
like the part that blows my mind is like
people like the only way you can fully
uh like enjoy control stories if you
read everything all the dialogue
everything
and the same people telling me because
you have to read stuff
for destiny to have a story the same
people telling me
that i need to read everything in the
game to understand what's going on in
control
and i'm just like i do this it's not
like
i would say once you get levitate
control it comes to a
man i hate this game do an enjoyable
game but by the time you get levitate
you might as well close the store
like okay it's literally like the last
hour and a half of the game
back to my experience um so
you know attic had to get his balls off
because he's tired of people talking
about control yeah
but i think control is by far one of
uh remedy's worst games wow and i'm
going to play it
i feel quantum break is by far a better
game
and i see why oh i agree 100 percent
yeah
when there's microsoft money thrown
behind the bushes
yeah yeah but yeah but one is higher in
the bushes and one is lower
i feel it's called control because it
has the best control of any remedy game
i've ever played all right so they
control and the fact that the physics
and the world and destructibility
um we're at a different age right now so
remedy has a bunch of tools
so i want to see the game with these
consoles the next game with these
consoles
because they have the the story
narrative down that was kind of missing
from this game i don't like
the the fake thrown into a world what's
going on here
uh who is this person i hate that i
really hate that fake psychological
thriller right so
um but right now i'm i'm halfway through
the game
i love uh the control aspect of it
the feeling of the game if i if i lose
in a fight is because i lost in a fight
it wasn't because of the controls and i
was mixed up with the buttons or
whatever the hell
like in quantum break right there's a
lot of times in quantum break
that i will definitely lose because of
the control
got you right so they they fixed it they
named it properly
um but again i'm still like the
character's small
you know but it's also zoomed out i felt
quantum break was their pinnacle and to
take a step down into this i'm like ah
i was expecting a little bit more okay
so
it's been pretty much the that or for
the controller yeah
you know every day over here i'll see
you on tuesday sir it'd be great
glorious to come back
down
[Laughter]
shout out to stephen clark says why am i
singing like janet jackson right now
control
anyway you know i got the song in my
head
i got in my head now you said it you
already had a huge crush on janet
jackson
football come on man and of course we
have the game ignition himself
this shinobi unlocked lord cognito
spread that relative to the roman iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need
to hit shout out to stitch we got snitch
right quick right quad control is
quantum break
yeah we got two that we missed we have
uh yeah we got
uh michael aka best size finest with
five out of super chat king i just got
my samsung
uh 90 q90t uh cute led yours godly on
this tv oh yeah
absolutely
i would just tell you this don't buy
another samsung tv for the next two
years
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know i've been
sitting here talking to 108 and other
people man
you know he's trying to talk me again
that nano cell but um yeah yeah
yo okay i'm with you i got the 9f so
that's inside the living room so
yeah yeah then we got stitch with the
two dollar super chat controllers
is quantum break 2.0
yeah we're caught up yeah that's true
yeah like i said uh no last word this
week man salute my brother bond is uh
going through some internet issues i
don't know what's going on with texas
man
don't know what's going on man well it
was all they shut down texas for uh earl
spence junior so
yeah maybe that's what the arrows in the
building made the truth you know what
you're saying yeah and uh yellow bees
you know they was doing it up but um
yeah man
but look man yeah so uh we will be back
probably next week have a good show
lined up for you guys um yeah i've
been on kind of transitioning my way
over to series x a little bit more full
time as you know
destiny 60 frames will be coming out on
tuesday so i'm just getting myself
acclimated
yo quick resume is working again
in all its glory so shout out to
everybody i put up a little fun video i
thought it was pretty cool because i
know when i first got the series x
i it wasn't working with yakuza and it
kind of turned me on really stop cause
i'm like damn i want to go i want to do
you realize song is the feature you
don't realize that you needed
yeah when you have it so when i had it i
was like damn every game except your
cools in the games i want to play
didn't wasn't doing it so now it looks
like they shout out to uh jason ron lord
jason shout out to um
major nelson he said it on his podcast
earlier this week that a lot of those
stuff they had disabled
until they could patch it for certain
games then they brought it back
so i was i'm gonna put it to the test so
yeah i put something up it was like
valhalla yakuza state of decay
you know what i'm saying and um gears
gives tactics
and just going back and forth and just
leaving at the exact
same state is so cool man so it actually
makes you multitask games a little bit
more so i've been doing that
also on the side i gotta give me a
little game pass shout out this is only
king second
i'm playing this stupid little game i
don't know why i like it it's called
um yes your grace
i heard about that yo what is that about
cause i heard about that i heard it was
good
yo it's bad funny so you're the king
right you know it's iron lord it's isla
it's it's all iron like you're the king
right so you sit on your little throne
or whatever whatever
so there's stuff like oh kind sir you
know we we have this problem here we
would like to know you know saying if
you could take care of it whatever
whatever and then like there'll be
little instances of the kingdom and you
got to go around the castle and then
also
like as soon as the games start like you
go on a wall with another group
so they captured one of your people's be
like yo he was hiding behind the bushes
what you would do it won't execute him
now or we're going whatever whatever but
it's like meanwhile our man is low
against this fight so what you want to
do
so everything has like a weighted
decision sounds like off with his head
he's a traitor
we will make an example of him right so
it's just fun little
medieval foolishness like it's just
funny like it's like 8-bit style
graphics
again free on game pass it's called
you're like
yes you're grace i just the name is fire
i got to get it because of the name
salute yesterday grace i thought it was
absolutely hilarious so i was rocking
with that but um yeah man now like i
said just trusted the uh
the uh what's called the resume feature
and all that other stuff getting ready
for tuesday as you already know it's
about to go down
but um yeah man we got some stuff did we
get somebody smith
uh yeah hold on a second yeah the last
smitty's map no no
sweetie with the photos who chat lord
cognito and the cognition
i believe why does that sound like a
band i will leave
right off for you brother on december
8th yeah that's like an 80s r
b band yeah that sounds like prince of
the revolution
i'm with that i'm with that i'm with the
cognition of so what's up so look man
look we're going to get into it before
we get it up okay megan we got a lot to
talk about but um yeah man
real quick you know it's that time of
the month we got to do what we do
y'all you know what i'm saying it's that
time of the month for lords of
gaming.net man
look man salute to the team salute to
the writers man everybody
involved it's that time of the month
we're going to definitely you know pay
homage to the great or editorial team
and all the riders so um
look super proud of what we're doing as
a website continuing to grow continuing
the trajectory and all that good stuff
so it is december so now we want to
acknowledge
the previous month's past winner at
lognet you know what i'm saying and um
describe of the month for november 2020
in a very fierce and competitive
high quality month of riding is eugene
chef maya once again aka
lord jean going back to back now he go
back to that well he went in his second
time this year
but salute salute to you brother y'all
be not only a fantastic writer and
reviewer
but um look now a lord of our hardware
reviews i saw the uh playstation 5 the
dual sense
the 3d headset review was really strong
also he did some um some fantastic
articles on siriusx load times
and um enhancements and a dirt 5
enhancement article that was very strong
so salute again
truly diverse outstanding talent lord
gene
you will now be immortalized on the site
for a month of speech
speech i like to call him very quick i
like to call him the human pre-order
machine
help to the realm with these consoles
and stuff like that has been
unmatched and we have super powers i'm
gonna tell you now
we need a quick speech babe oh man it's
great to be back thanks for having me
back
uh you know thank you guys thank you cog
thank you
josh uh thank you dizzy uh undead
mancho you know you know uh i love
working with you guys it's great
and without them you know the stuff
wouldn't get edited and be put up so
um it's it's really great working you
guys appreciate you brother man fanta
is that a dream cast on the back of you
i'm seeing like some classic consoles
you out here
what's that you know i need to be your
baby yeah you know um
you know if you don't have five or six
dreamcast are you even a gamer
i respect that he got him on deck yo
that's what's up man but salute to you
bro like i can't you you've been killing
it and again fierce competition as well
but once again you know doing your thing
so you already know make sure you hit up
lord swag well first of all you were
immortalized on lords of gaming.net for
the month so go check out
lawrencegamer.net
you can check out gene you can check out
his work he will be there describe of
the month is up
and um you got to hit upload man get
that up that that free uh
iop royal swag of your choosing you know
what i'm saying maybe that log that
brothers
listen man go for the sweater go for
this i say go for the game
listen listen it's getting a little cold
he's getting a little poke
go for the sweat don't listen to him
with a sweater
and if you get a chance if you get a
chance
since you're a two-time winner i would
say throw in the bean
throw in a beanie
you want to be standing next to the
christmas tree
you know you want to be out there with
your mug you want it
you know you want to do your thing man
so look who's
getting a little snuggy
to get that you saw my brother fantastic
i have to go to king because i get the
better gear from him you know
you like that shirt right nice yeah
listen man we ate
we got that premium budget like
we gotta deal with what we can deal with
salute to you man outstanding work once
again bro thank you so much
listen when i told you that gene has
superpowers i just want to say the one
story again
but we was at one place right and gene
was like yo he sent a picture of the
club that he was at it was
oh he did someone take a picture of
where we was
and we was getting free food yo i turned
around i swear to god
we just sent it yes i turned around to
just to say like something to macho
and i turned to my right and gene was
standing in
our spot already a lot of people sweat
popped off and said nothing that's the
fastest
i've ever seen yeah uber i don't even
know how he got through uh security
that's that i was like
[Laughter]
powers that's my guy absolutely you know
enjoy your day sir
and of course what i'm gonna say solve
we got some bills you're gonna play with
that stuff
uh speaking of patreon uh we still have
a couple winners from
last month's patreon that has have not
seen me lord sparty on
and uh oh god i forgot the other person
but anyway
this is totally my fault i was in the
bushes this week and i completely forgot
four people today so i will we'll do
patreon next week the new patreon that
gives
our old patrons uh another week to get
at me
get at me and get but as
you guys have seen on twitter we have
had a cyberpunk giveaway
going on and today is the day
where we are now starting because i
reported
i need to see that trademark application
and being that all trademark
applications go through me
yeah you're crazy dude that was your
that's your that's yours
the winner of our cyberpunk 2077
giveaway it oh of course big shout out
to lawrence now though for having to do
with the hours of the bs as he always
does
bot counts but anyway oh the winner
is lord baron j67 at twitter
to you sir um i have your info so i will
be
uh checking you in the dms and i will be
getting you that code
um did we say platform or it was
it was xbox for sure whatever it was
xbox for sure yeah okay
if it was winner's choice because you
know playstation be funny about that
yeah all right so we all just a little
bit we'll give give them one more time
so
you guys are aaron j67 baron j67 man
like i said hit ups off get your
winnings
so we congratulations congratulations
man get that flash that get get it all
man
and you start downloading from today yes
yes guys
so look we're gonna get into it man a
lot of show to discuss but uh now we got
the business finished we got the scribe
of the month finished
you know what i'm saying we gotta focus
on lord k
mega you know what i'm saying his video
game system history and of course what
led him to his amazing youtube channel
and that iconic grg
podcast so okay mega man let's start
from the beginning what was some of the
first video game systems you had what
kind of got you into gaming
all right so um i've told this story
like a million times uh but you know
what basically
i got started up my mom uh used to go to
a laundromat
and of course you know i'm i'm young i'm
like three years old i'm being bad i'm
running around and stuff that's what you
would tell me i mean
you know but um you know when i was at
the laundry mat she gave me some
quarters
and to play an arcade uh and it was a
table arcade so that kind of tells you
my age
uh so yeah so we go in and we do that
and uh play it as pac-man
that keeps my attention and then it
moves over to arcades to you know to the
arcades where people
actually the tall arcades um and uh
then it went to the uh atari 2600
um and then to the nes and um
uh but well i take that back i got the
uh
uh colecovision um
i got the colecovision my grandfather
got me that and then i got then i got
the nes and then i moved over to
uh question because you just certainly
passed there
all right okay all right when you went
from the atari
um did you get the pac-man on atari yes
and it was kind of disappointing because
it wasn't anything like the arcade i was
already mad about that
yeah but i mean you're talking about a
young kid man i was just happy that i
had the
the uh atari because all right you know
i've never seen that right so you went
to kaliko
did you get the pac-man for coleco no
no i had i had one game and it was a
football game
and i didn't even know how to play it so
i i barely bought that thing again
yeah yeah yeah yeah no it was a it was a
football game i rarely got a chance to
play it
uh so and i was just mostly on my atari
so that's why you talk about the
early days yeah yeah yeah yeah because
it was like night and day because i had
both of them
and then when i went over to
colecovision i was like oh i see now i'm
playing with power
but yeah no no no no things look better
over there but it just
i i just the controller was different
everything was like
um uh you know i had uh dodge them
i had uh i was one of the people who had
e.t
i didn't know how to play it oh um
nobody did it
i didn't i didn't know how to play it i
got so far and then i was like i don't
know what i'm doing
you know um yeah oh i had a pitfall
and i had um uh
pong of course of course and then
that and then and then i had pac-man but
that was really the only five games that
i had back then
um and then if also um you know it was
crazy because my
my my mom and my grandparents they
always thought i was just an
idiot because i would be playing this
stuff and then they were like
my grandfather's like boy why are you
always messing with these funny toy
electronic boxes why you want these
things but they
but they still supported me man they
still supported it and got it and it was
great
and if you remember if you go back there
used to be those little portable
uh donkey kong and tabletops
yeah yeah i remember i got that for
christmas man i was so elated
wow
because you just dropped a major bomb
and something we don't really talk about
you know saying king and saul
can relate is that the arcade mini table
top scene was a
big thing back in the day and king of
the chess
the little portables before game boy
when you had the one game
it was like static images of black and
white and they had two buttons
yeah the game that you got in trouble
for king you know what
i'm a donkey kong junior i stole the
money from the um
like i got tore up that day because my
boy i'm never going to forget he would
he
would barely
that's right i'm shaming you people
barely threw me under the bus he
snitched that's the first of my first
encounter with a six nine
um straight in my face right now
wow he did it wow
i wanted to shout that out because it's
something i guess a gaming culture
you know from our generation that we
don't talk about a lot because those are
a big thing they were many different of
these particles
and then they had the ones that had like
a clam shell that had a time screen and
a downstream
you know what i'm saying
there's one that i had that wasn't it
wasn't a coleco one it was
it was another one i forgot it was
called it was like alien attack or
something like that
that thing is worth right
upwards of two grand are you serious wow
yeah
wow yeah wow thank you
that's crazy
just a friendly reminder to stitch with
the fight off which had just the front
announcement both xbox series consoles
can emulate older consoles like
playstation one places two dreamcast and
gamecube and so much more
yes yeah the trueback can pad
yo i'm gonna tell you that that's a uh
unbeknown
byproduct of good engineering yeah
good engineering that's what's up what
else yeah it's funny because i yeah
stinger was talking about that because i
was thinking about buying a polymega as
well mm-hmm
hmm
yeah there we go
with the orange case and the green
buttons
that's why everybody's going crazy over
the game and watch because that that's
not
all just i mean you have it's coming out
but
i got it yo those would have i had
popeye
pac-man oh man classics baby
y'all all y'all all y'all had family
with money i
got just donkey kong
no no no no no this was you know
this is the thing you asked for
christmas time right you go to the
grandparents
my grandparents were very good about
getting me exactly what i
asked for like a lot of times
grandparents who did mess it up
you know messing up whatever my
grandparents were very very good about
getting me exactly
the assets yeah i didn't have none of
that so what i had was me
right so let me tell you something out
in the streets i'm eight nine years old
i'm making sure i'm getting what i gotta
get
that's what it is
this boy was out there trying to get a
buck and i was not stopping
bro i was the same way i was out there
cutting yards i was doing all types of
stuff
man when i was younger about 10 years
old so yeah i totally know
i was bailing hay at 12 years old man
you know
that's why i'm as big as i am now
little devil back to you came back i
just i just had to get that ball no no
no no no
it's all good all right and yes yeah i
went to the nes
and actually that was the first time
that i actually got
into a single player game that and that
was
rygar rygar was the game of my life
right there
it still touches my heart and so it took
me some years later on when i got older
to finally beat that game
but yeah but i but it was but it was
it drew me in and then of course just
everything else with nintendo
i remember when we went to he used to go
to back in the days going to walmart and
he was and they would have it on display
and there would be a row of kids that
was there and so yeah i would sit there
we'd be playing
and and then there was balloon fight and
ice climbing and all that i was like i
gotta get it i gotta
get all this so that's when i started
like
trying to you know compromise with my
mom and and
i was like hey you know i'll do some
chores i'll do this and do that and she
was like
boy you're gonna have to go earn your
own money if you want to try to get this
yeah so uh and then eventually she got
it for me for christmas but
and that's when i kind of realized that
santa claus wasn't real
those young realizations yeah yeah yeah
the realization i see to put it back in
the truck and so i
i played it off but i was excited as
hell i would i knew exactly where i was
like man where is that
but uh yeah but yeah but yeah i salute
my mom for that
but yeah she so so it was so it was that
then uh you know just all the great
russian attack
hold on i can't let you try that you're
naming greatness right now you touch me
you can't just gloss over russian attack
right next to the double dragon you
already know that that was a very shady
spot but they had
a russian attack they had their russian
attacks and that just had the alarm that
go off
and the man the main character looked
like flip from gi joe
yeah yes yes
all right so then of course then you
moved to uh metal gear
and then you had um those kid icarus
um i'm just just trying to go through my
head of all those games that i've been
playing for nintendo i mean you just
just so many well now take this i was
the one game that i was most
disappointed about on the
on the nes was ninja gaiden because i
was playing it at the arcade
and i was you know and and then uh and
then and then you know you just go and
do that but then of course it was
turtles and time
there was there's just so many games
that i was just playing on nintendo it
was just ridiculous
so then um i've eventually moved on to
uh sega
um you know and
the uh the um genesis
yeah and so then uh i got the genesis
and by this time i'm older you know i'm
i'm
i'm you know um pockets good do you want
my thing yes
well yeah you know i'm doing my thing
i'm you know
you when you win purchase your pockets
was good
so yeah and then of course there was
shinobi oh yeah um
that it was the one thing why i never
forget shinobi is because
the very end when you when you before
you got to the last boss there was a
jump
yes and i couldn't that jump [ __ ]
i don't know how many days it took me to
get to just to make that jump to get
because when you got to the boss the
boss was easy to kill but
you that jump to get to him was awful
so um yeah yeah yeah yeah so it kind of
reminds me
it reminds me of ninja gaiden when you
had to make that jump to get to the fir
to fight the boss for the first time and
all that
then i was like what is going on here
but anyway but yeah but there's nobody
there was uh
uh bill walsh football of course yeah
there was
uh nba live just just uh
you know eternal champions um you know
i made the mistake right so i think he
bill washed
and madden came out at the same time no
man was out before the end because there
was people that were playing on pc
but yeah it was a time where they both
like had dropped around the same time
yeah my stupid behind went to um 181st
street
and i grew up a wash
yeah before i even played man i was
playing bill walsh and i was playing joe
mona
well bro it was ridiculous those
graphics at that time was
out of this world and so when i finally
did start playing madden
and and then you had that other flip you
know the way that man used to play
like you know man plays now the front
the front you know but
yeah because you know joel montana
played on the side so
yes so and i was kind of like whoa i
mean i you know and so i was playing
madden
from that angle because they used to
have that angle and i was like oh this
ain't working so i had to flip it back
but
um but yeah i mean just i mean there
were so many games that i played i
there's just so many lists i mean i see
there's somebody in the chat that
brought up
bad dudes i played um you know
matter of fact i do need to go back to
the nes and bring up a couple of games
because they i got them on xbox right
now
um and and on pc um was dodgeball
that was that was a classic that game
was crazy double dragon
uh there was another game that was
called renegade yeah yeah
that was the type of train station where
they used to try to yeah
yeah yeah
there wasn't too many nintendo games
that weren't hard that's why when people
talk about
you know oh these games can we get easy
bro there was no easy button back in our
days man
yeah the arcades and when you was
messing with the nintendo or the sega at
the time
that was no that was no easy mode i mean
ghosting goblins and
you know ghosts and ghouls and you know
no no no no no no no no no no i was hard
as yeah very difficult rygar
was really difficult that's that was the
thing too like i mean
there was just so many games out there
that was difficult uh uh
uh what was it um uh uh
kid nikki i think that was called where
he had that we had the spinach swords
and stuff like that
that the game uh by you billy i mean
just touch the game yes
oh man bro i the one game that made me
rage quit
and and i was renting games back then so
you know i would have to go to place a
little store shout out to video haven
out there
out there shout out to you guys i know
but they're they're gone but
yeah as as
my boy would say they're the bushes um
they uh but the thing of it is that they
uh um i used to go rent those games over
there and
there was a game it was captain planet
and
yeah that game was so difficult
bro i i got all my kids smooth my inner
kids moved man i
i broke my nintendo controller i was
pissed i was like what do you do
you know the sega and then uh sega cd
um and then that was you know there was
a job man you know sonic and then
eternal champion cd because you know i'm
big into the fighters and stuff like
that
and so um then i then i then i had to
make a choice
because at this point i'm like you know
moms and then wasn't kicking any money
down
like boy you weighed
i want this second saturn you know cause
i'm a sega dude right
oh that's what's up i'm learning yeah so
i was like what's the second saturn in
the inside my mom was like uh
you know so
yeah your grandparents are like no no we
done with you on that one
uh and so so i was like man i also you
know i'm working at a pizza joint doing
my thing at this time i you know i'm
i'm uh i'm i'm working working just
going to school playing sports stuff
like that so then i would go and um
i had to make a decision because you
know i i had i had my son
in high school so so i mean i got all
these responsibilities but i still want
a console
wow and so anyway so that's a lot so i
said uh so there was a choice
and then there was the playstation and
it was cheaper boy
and so i was like man and so shout out
to my boy rest in peace um
freddie b um he um
he he he got one his family got him one
and so anyway got him a playstation
right and so there and so he was like
hey man
i think you might need to what get this
yeah i said man i want it man but i
don't know so
you know long story short i eventually
get the playstation instead of the
saturn
and and and then and then he had like
five games
and i was talking about that lineup and
so then he
he had five games and so he was like hey
man i'll let you borrow two okay
i said word i said cool so there was a
one game that was 99 football
and then the other and the other game
was the mighty tech
life was over then life was over now i
understand when people may listen to me
now
they may they may think of me as
something different but i tell you after
that
moment i became what i call a
playstation stain
it was over right
legend of a guy a legend of lagoon
let's go back to that second let's go
back to that yeah
all right so did you see it in the
arcade um oh yeah yeah okay
and when you got home and you had the
same exact thing because
it blew my mind yeah your heart was
already broken with pac-man
all right so we're back to atari with
the pac-man in the heart being broken
cause you saw the arcade and it wasn't
what you got
at home you got bam bam bam
wow you see they're tekken in the arcade
and it played
better in your house with now that's how
you
feel bro i i lost my mind you know what
i'm saying
and so like i would have my son right
here next to me and i would just be
right there and i'm just playing
just just hours and hours and hours
protecting and game day
and then when i got my i started
building up my library and doing all
this stuff uh
eventually you know because i mean you
still have to get some lacking yeah
i still got a phony kid yeah yeah i got
to feed this guy
damn man why
oh yeah yeah my son actually he he did
uh he was going and doing those
tournaments uh for those
he was trying to get into mlg i met fact
i have a picture of him on facebook
baby right shout out oh man yeah yeah
thank you thank you appreciate that
my son and my daughter man you know
shout out to xavier shout out to jasmine
um
you know they do the things that now
they've grown now so
um but you know shout out to them but
yeah no he
he he was in the call of duty space he
was doing those call of duty tournaments
there for a little while and then
he changed up and and while he was going
to college and then he changed up once
they did the whole switch from
playstation to
i mean from xbox to playstation and then
the crew that he had they
there were some people that didn't have
a playstation or they didn't want to
play on playstation so
that kind of fizzled out but he was
actually you know
he he was kind of the ins he was kind of
inspiring me to start doing streaming
because he was
doing things his editing and everything
was solid i was like yo
and so i was like all right i might try
to get on and try to
do this stuff you know um but you know
but he did his stuff but shout out to
him he's
you know he's responsible he's a man now
so he's he's doing this thing he's like
he's lost
he's he's looking he's he's about to
women now trying to find him
i guess the one i mean i'm because the
the reason why i say that is because
you're playing attack and you're playing
your games and he's sitting next to you
yeah you can plant in that seed in them
i mean
you you was passing on that that
beautiful hobby
you know that hobby that you love so
that's that's a beautiful thing
no doubt to this day my son will come
over to come over to the house every
once in a while and he'll say uh
drop in that check him because he wants
to he wants to take it from him
he wants to take it from me i mean there
was times that he would he would beat me
but overall he just couldn't and then um
especially when i was in my prime yeah
yeah i go well well bro bro this is
this is serious take don't give me them
characters yo yo oh okay so
we uh we used to what we used to do is
we used to and the homies used to come
through and stuff and then they would
bring people over because they were like
man this is crazy i remember i went on
this
this is so awesome bro i went on
i went on a 100 game winning streak oh
my god
with kazuya because i used to know
kazuya the purple with the purple soup
or does it talk take it too or this the
first one the uh the first
oh they're checking from one two three
from one to three but i mean
at that time it was tekken two when i
had that hundred streak and then i had
uh
and then they had uh uh i was playing
with kazooie i knew it's 10 hit combo
punch and you knew the side steps yeah
yeah yeah and then also
if you had and you had two versions of
the super move you had the shorter
version
and you had the long volume bro
let me tell you i played tekken so much
at one time like i would play with the
koreans out there at the arcade
yo yo bro
that's why when they say when people
talk about fighters and then they kind
of downgrade them like that like there's
no sense of competition like fighters
one on one five skill against myself
let's
get it and since i've gotten older my
skills you know i'm saying shout out to
trizzy and game down sights and all the
guys when they come over and we play and
core in them and sir x-men in them and
we go in there and
and uh i play against these young boys
and and i just don't have the finger
speed like
but and so like at second seven i get
you know
it's hard to beat them yeah to be to be
templar in um
in a game in a trizy but when we go to
tekken tag when we go back
i still have it i still haven't do that
hip-hop
because yeah i'm sorry you know no no
you're good you're good brother you're
good
what it is is that like tekken is so
important to the lords
like attacking forged us as men
because it was like oh you better than
you think you better it's like
we're gonna sit there we used to do
tournaments where no one could leave
until the other person beat one person
10
times i had a 10 fight differential so
it could go
on literally hours
it's my boy right is my boy ken right
here
you know the first one to get to 10. so
i know
ken this is my strategy i know you know
ken skill is
up there right but you have to incite
him
to bring it out so i changed my strategy
right my strategy normally is to talk
heavy dog crap to you
yeah how do you throw you off your gate
that works for certain individuals
he feeds off of it and he gives the
energy
back right so what i did this time they
left because they went to the store to
go get something to eat they said okay
yo this is going to take a while
we're going to get something to eat so i
had ken up in the room
and he had got one win because that was
the same i said good one that was a good
one
he's like good one we friends so oh yeah
yo that was close one that was a close
one yo
i stretched it out and i got to 10 pulls
right
and and i beat him
i put the controller there and i said i
got your hand
he started talking crazy so reckless
he came back from the store he had tears
in his eyes
so we like oh it was like that so then
so ken was like
nah it was all love i don't know where
this is coming from
oh man it's like he got betrayed like he
thought it was like an exhibition
let me tell you the the competition
that's that's for me it's like when i
could just
when you step into a room full of wolves
you know i'm saying it's one of those
things where
you don't know what's going to happen
and i mean this is this is with madden
nba
real nba live nba 2k uh you know
fighting games especially you know you
you know i remember uh one time i was in
a room full of full of people we were
just playing street fighter alpha
and um street fighter alpha it was
street fighter alpha 2.
yeah and next to you know like you know
homie was sitting here and he was
thrashing people and one dude you know
he was kind of new and he came in there
and said something the next thing you
know he popped off and then yeah it
started it was a real fight
bro yeah yeah yeah bro it was one of
those things where
the crap listen that same person that
king was talking about
there was a time before cognito cognito
used to live
in cognito's family like owns a
brownstone right
so cognito used to live in an apartment
with his mom when he was younger he had
a very small room right before he
he took an apartment upstairs and that's
where we mostly hung out so
we were in cognito's tiny room where it
was like standing room only right
so lord ken was standing in front of a
king
standing next
but i was next to ken so he said
something
they they got a little too reckless king
was not happy
and all you thought was the fist coming
and then
i was in the middle of it and i'm like
nah so you can't be fighting in the crib
oh
[Music]
like we were standing there watching
people play games yeah you see how big i
am right
so it was the best environment to grab a
dude
oh yeah
at the end of the day what i always
respect about tekken
and the competitive fighting scene was
the competition putting it on the line
you know what i'm saying people are
coming from all over like we used to
have people come from all over and say
yo i play this i'm tech and i'm nice
with this character right or where
we like we used to treat it like the
kung fu flicks but when they used to go
up to bruce lee and they used to attack
oh yeah theater that's how it was so
it's like oh you challenging me
no no you gotta put it on you know what
i'm saying we gotta put it on right now
we gotta we gotta settle this like i
used to have people pull up we go to the
arcade the bowling alley
suddenly like it was that it was just a
different time it wasn't just talking to
trolling too much
it was more like put your skill against
my skill
let's see who's the best you know what
i'm saying right and that's we come from
that we come everything with the laws
was competitive it was it was fighting
it was halo
it was it was madden it was nba it was
whatever yeah and everybody you know the
wrestling games you know what i'm saying
like
it i will say this it definitely i feel
for my generation it definitely built
character a bit
yeah and you really at the end of the
day you have respect
because regardless of what will lose you
it's like okay you know what i got to
get the dojo
yeah right better you know what i'm
saying because this this move but it's
like i remember there was a there was a
time
where king was terrorizing us with eddie
gordon with
eddie gordo and tiger oh and then he
used to put tiger on
with the afro and he'd be beating you
with the goats and taught and you gotta
understand king's mouth is reckless so
not only is he
nice
[Applause]
yes it was crazy it was great but it was
a long single but i had to get that off
because
no no we cut from that same thing
brother exactly that's the one thing
that i will always
miss is i i love the online gaming scene
that's why i was i was
late to join the online scene because of
the
the couch co-op era and
i mean and i learned that from really
actually from from from you know the the
from starting from the nes going on to
the to the sega
to playstation and that i do miss that
era because
there's every once in a while you know
if we're older you know not too many
friends come over like they used to
but when they do they still want to you
know play the old stuff and it's still
fun it gives you that nostalgia
um but yeah you definitely write it
bill's character um
and and then like when people start
chirping like when i'm doing fight night
and people come in oh man i got my crew
with y'all y'all suck y'all blah blah
blah blah
blah bro get in here and get on these
sticks
please you know that's what i'm saying
like this this isn't this isn't this
isn't like some kind of fake
um but yeah there was also um you know
of course the dreamcast which was just
legacy
i i never really was a fan of the uh n64
because of the controller or the
gamecube i did buy it for my for my kids
but
they you know they played it my son
became a huge smash brothers fan
and and and uh you know mario fan and
stuff like that but i
myself kind of was evolving you know
when you get to that point to where you
get older and then
you're working a lot you're doing a
whole bunch of other things and you're
kind of thinking man you know gaming
it might be i might be getting past
games right and and you know and then
next thing you know the dreamcast comes
and i'm like whoa whoa whoa whoa you
know you know over here
yeah yeah yeah all of that you know soul
calibur all these games even though you
know again he brought that nostalgia
from what was coming from the
playstation one which is
one of my favorite eras in gaming of all
time
but um but you know they came to the
dreamcast and then okay so
the last part here which kind of
involves everything
where i'm at let's get it um you know
like i said shout out to my boy freddie
b
he he hit me up and he was telling me
you know he was out there uh at college
uh at uh cookman um
and uh he was a running back out there
and he was saying man there's
people telling about some kind of weird
console man i think i'm finna cop one
i'm like what and i'm like man what are
you talking about and so he says man i
think i'm gonna cop one and then i was
like all right whatever so then
right after my other homeboy came from
iraq
um he said hey man i know that you be
playing these games and stuff like that
i got this new console
he says i kind of want you to try it out
and and i and at that point once the
dreamcast kind of defaults i got back in
that phase again like you know i got my
playstation 2 but i'm
growing it and i'm you know i don't want
to play the gamecube you know i'm kind
of moving on
um then he says man come and try to you
know learn this game i said this is a
new playstation or something he said
no he says this thing is something else
so i go over there and so i
and so while looking first thing i see
is the controller and i'm laughing at
that
yeah like why this thing look like a
dinner plate man what is this thing and
so
you know we clown in and stuff and so he
says man i got only two games on this
thing he says but
you know let's go he says man in this
got a hard drive i said where's the
memory card he's just got a hard drive
and i didn't you know i'm ignorant i'm
like
what is this no he says no i mean i'm
telling you man and so then
the first game that i play on it was
brute force but i kind of didn't know
how to play it because of the way the
controller was yes
yeah and then so and so you know i was
like okay this looks cool but yeah you
know i'm i'm uh
so he says all right well this other
game man come on man help me learn how
to play it because
it looks intriguing and so i so we get
it there we're learning and like
we're trying to both learn the controls
and we're playing it and then it takes
about three four hours
before we really grasp it and then some
other homeboys come because we
you know they want to go to the club
this saturday night and saturday evening
or
afternoon and then we're all talking
about how many we'll go to the club i
said yeah but we're trying to figure
this out so he says man he's got four
player split screen
it's over oh that's so i said and so so
we so so everybody's trying to learn how
to play this thing
and so then at the point which we we we
lose track of time and they say yeah man
we got to go help you know get ready so
we go to the club
uh sunday
club is in the back like 9 30 in the
morning
the next day the next day we are all
sitting there like
did we just play a video game all damn
night long like we were kids
and and and that's what it was it was
the mighty halo
and i hated shooters i am not double 07
was the only shooter that i really
enjoyed
and halo changed everything up that
that that nostalgia as a kid back when i
was you know playing with my sega
and all that and i was on the genesis
not all of that
came back it rushed and i've never and
i've never left again and even
though i've supported playstation from
day one you know and i still
continue to play support for playstation
playstation still has its moments where
it gets me hype and things like that but
it's not like what it does with what
xbox is giving me
and and it's just and that's why you
know i kind of look at it from the
perspective of like i understand when
playstation fans
you know they're they're happy about
this and stuff but
but when they degrade the mighty halo
it's kind of like bro you just don't
understand man you know
it's just like for any other game that
you've played out there
that that gives you like if it's got a
war if it's something before that if
it's you know
siphon filter whatever you know if it
gives you that feeling then
it's got you and that's that's where
xbox got me in and i've been
i've been riding with xbox ever since
that's my primary console of choice
i want to like i said before we move on
i got to expand it because
you know people forget how
transformative
halo was you know i mean king could tell
you i mean we have people
in the projects setting up stations
outside lan parties
yes yo i had the local drug dealers
sitting on the corner
they they made a deal with the store to
use their cables
to play play halo at the store
four screens dudes standing out there
they like give me hold on man they like
cop and go man get by here
and they are playing halo and then that
change from yo we're not selling drugs
no more
you know i gotta get a job and i gotta
do this other stuff
because you couldn't bring that around
where we were
right so if you wanted to hang out with
us
yeah we respect what you do yeah that's
your business
but if you want to hang with us you got
to stop you got it you got to yeah yeah
you got to go
because the block where cog lived
it was brown stones you know some some
tenements around the corner
but the family environment it took me
from out of you know every time i turn
around i got a fear for my life and all
that other stuff
actually when i get to the block when i
hit that block when i hit clay
i was safe i felt safe so we didn't want
to bring
any of that negativity from outside
right to our safe haven
so you had to wash your hands at that if
you wanted to hang out with us
and so many dudes changed their life
because of
that's the thing like a lot of people
don't realize that's why it's like we
always gonna ride for gaming
regardless because no one can tell me
how that did not positively influence
my circle you know what i'm saying right
and kept us from doing other things that
we shouldn't have been doing you know
what i'm saying so
at the end of the day it's like i said
the competition the camaraderie
the regular bringing people together the
fun the hour like you said
hours upon hours of fun
you look up you cannot believe that many
it was so crazy like i don't know if
y'all remember like remember nobody
beats the wiz and all that like we need
to go to the wiz to go get tvs
so everybody can have their own screen
for the lan party
you know what i'm saying we had to get
the lynxes cable we learned about
cabling we learned about ethernet cables
like we learned on the fly we like we
must continue this
this is the most the greatest whether it
be blood goats hang them high
four players you know see it getting it
on yeah and
the rivalry and the fun it was just
nonstop and then that evolved
so again for the people like it's like
you said i understand why xbox is
important because
and then for us you get older now right
yeah everybody is married
they live in here they move but now xbox
live comes along
boy and now it's like yo we it's like
we're still in the crib
but we're talking to each other from
each other's and it brings everybody
back together again so
i ain't got to get dressed now and i can
just sit there in my boxes
i i want to make another point to um if
i can it's
basically for me is the one
and another special moment for me was um
what you know the halo it changed
everything you know so we would
you know i would say this so i i go to
my very first
um game uh um i go to like gamestop to
go pick up
my very first pre-order game yes sir and
that was halo 2.
and so my son my son was into it and of
course like he was talking about the lan
parties i took my son to one of those
land parties
uh shout out to frosty you know i'm not
i'm sure you know
you know that you know actually okc he
had he his pops had a gaming store
and he so at night after after the
gaming store was over
then we that's where we used to have the
halo we should call it halo nights and
we would get and
do the lan parties there then that's
where we learned it but anyway i took
him there
kind of messed him up like whoa what is
this and so then he got into halo and
then so
i told him i said you know what i you
know you want to be a part of this
i want to sit there and i want to call
into school for you if you want to come
in here and stand in line
but i didn't think that the line was
going to be that long
and for halo 2. and and you know saying
i was just thinking it was going to be
just like you know 10 you know 5 10
minutes or so but that line
it was one of the biggest lines that
i've ever seen next to uh grand theft
auto 5. those were the two biggest lines
that i've ever seen
uh out there at uh at uh um uh
crossroads mall
i mean not crossworld small but um
heritage mall here in this ball
and uh get up there that line was almost
all the way
halfway around the damn uh the the damn
mall itself
and we stayed there we didn't get the
game until like i mean
three hours and then you know that
moment
with me and my son it it it was cherry
you know i cherished it it was it was
just something that bonds
and you know of course my daughter she
didn't care
but you know but my son that and that
what
got him into the competition because he
would be there and watch me in the
homies be there and play and he would
and all that stuff so that's i think for
me
that's what it's all about i mean just
for the gaming
situation overall is why i'm so
um so so down for xbox and and want them
to succeed and want them to
to do everything that they need to do to
get back to that 360 og era
uh you know xbox era because of uh the
fact that
the the impact it had on me and my
family preach it brother yeah you
listen man we don't talk we we share a
lot
of history brother like it is very eerie
see every and even in the chat
they preach they bring you up you know
everyone's story seems to be very
similar
you know coming up and it's just amazing
just to see what games let's get these
super chats over there
we got to move on a little bit give me a
second
everybody was lit
i see them shout out renegades
good day gentlemen my series x arrived
last week incredibly happy saving for
worthy tv no doubt my brother enjoy that
then we got smitty smith with the two
dollar super chat anybody remember
bad dudes as a matter of fact listen as
a matter of fact
in that same store that god was talking
about we had russian attack
they had bad dudes they're bad
[Music]
you know it hasn't aged very well if you
uh
all those games renegade all that stuff
they had the re-releases
a lot of them i got a lot of them on the
switch right the the hamster releases
um and they are kid perfect yeah a lot
of those games very
[Music]
i thought he was bruce lee for real in
that joke bro
continue continue continue there we go
it's time to get it to be messy king
david do you know that playstation 5
can't play ps1 or ps2 games
well um that is true i have a card i
have a console for you sir it's called
the xbox there isn't
you can get the series s you know for
the low low price of uh 299 and you can
have
all of that dreams come true again
what else you guys thought we got
sweetie smith uh with the five dollars
which had video games have literally
saved my damn
life it kept me from doing and getting
arrested
on and so forth the book of acts yeah
that's definitely got it
bro talk about it talk about that
scripture right there that scripture we
could
yes yeah we're good we're caught up yeah
master look man tremendous [ __ ] man
mega man we could talk for hours you
know about all the game is insane
it's insane bro but i gotta ask you
about transitioning now
getting into youtube and of course
creating that grg podcast so like how
did that hold up
all right so you know i'll be a lot more
shorter than i was about the whole game
in history um
the thing of uh it was crazy because i
um
you know i listened to bgst i was
listening to to all these other guys and
stuff you know angry joe
and all these other people and and that
was towards the end of the generation i
didn't really know anything about
youtube or anything like that
and then i just so happened to listen to
uh some guys from uh
uh from from a thing called uh we game
here
and so i was digging everything like
that and then there was one time that i
you know i first just got my
my um x1 and then we was still uh and we
was playing titanfall and then something
like that and then i got hit up
you know because i you know i've hit
people up in the chats and stuff like
that
and then there was a person named big
kahuna
and i was like oh what's up you know i
was like oh hey [ __ ]
you know i you know and you get star
struck for a minute you don't say they
got big kahuna it was kids moving there
with rosie grime
let's go yeah oh yeah yeah yeah shout
out to them man it's so
i ain't hurt and uh i ain't heard that
name in a long time
but i know shout out to ross and grime
man
and detroit reaper they were they were
in there and then so you know
how when you listen to their podcast or
you listen to all that other stuff
you trying to talk like a podcaster to
them right
you know how it goes right you know sir
and so then uh bitcoin was like man you
know your stuff man because
you know talking about history and stuff
like that it was gaming and then uh kids
move just came out and he was like hey
man
why don't you try to do this uh this uh
this stuff going on with them
with the youtube thing and i was like oh
no ain't nobody gonna listen to my
country
this move was like how kids what was to
you addict was to be that's literally
what happened
yeah and so i so him kahuna was just
trying to bait and then
and then you know me and rise me and
rosa grande was kind of tight you know
because we would talk and stuff and then
he
was like man you know he cold he
co-signed it that's himself
so i was like all right i'm gonna go
ahead and try it i was telling my
my ex-girlfriend at the time uh you know
that i was going to do it of course she
thought it was stupid
that's the label
and so uh yes i was going to do it so i
did my very first video
um and the very first comment and i got
a comment
and i was hyped like yo when the comment
was like this video
is garbage you should never talk again
so i'm like oh my god
i was like whoa rough
and it wasn't you know it was just
basically talking about my history or
whatever about you know what i knew
about gaming
and uh i think that's what the the
evolution of learning of getting that
thick skin
and and so i was like you know what i'm
gonna make another video i'm not going
to let this deter me or whatever but it
didn't hurt my feelings i was like well
i mean i put i put all this time into
this doing this i don't read
none of them stuff right bro the very
first comment
like like everybody resonate you gotta
stop thinking about it
right right right like hold on hold on
so um
so then after that you know i i started
making more videos and the next thing
you know i uh kiss moving them they
introduced me to uh dre
king dre and uh t yes and then they was
like hey man you want to be a part of uh
you know we game here so i was hyped
like yeah you know i'll be down for it
and so
we did that um didn't really ever
talk about gaming we talked i was doing
i was on a king dre stuff talking about
sports which i enjoy i love sports as
well so
you know so we did a little bit of that
but never really talked about gaming and
so i was also watching somebody that i
really really and i still admire
and that was the shadows always and
that's kind of if you
see my earlier videos i patent my style
kind of off of him with the music in the
background
and the quality of the video the you
know try to come with a you know
uh intellectual um delivery
and i just everything that would be
shadows was doing was what i was
wanting to do for that's what i thought
was the right way to do it
and so um you know and then you know i
hit him up he he hit me up and
and and so we was chopping it back and
forth but i had to but my first
opportunity to get into the gaming scene
you know was from anchorman v
because he seemed to be in the middle of
a lot of numbers right
right right he gave me i was nervous
oh man i was so nervous and uh then i
started talking with
shadows we started doing stuff and then
i met range e4 and
and just a whole bunch of other people
and then it just kind of
evolved and moved up and then that's
when i started uh
talking with uh you know i finally got
to to meet uh
zaire or next-gen and and crapping them
and then they
eventually you know ask me to to be a
part of bgst
uh but before that i need to go back i
need to give some more representations
of history
and so uh before that i i stepped away
for a while because i mean i got out
i told you it was my ex-girlfriend so
all right things like things
i had to step away bro i had to get away
you know i was like no
i'm out i'm done um so i had to start
over so i was gone for about a year or
so and then
my boy infrared beam yeah we would talk
and so he was telling me like hey man
you know you need to get back into it i
was like ah man no
no no no no he's like i'll get back to
you he says i know his homeboy
you know what i'm saying he says man i
think you need to talk to him and so it
was 100.
and so uh yeah so and so then i i
uh yeah 100 yeah yeah 100 good people
and so uh you know i was talking 100
and then he was like hey man hey
i like what you're doing man i like what
you're doing man i was like all right
bro i say okay
well bro and so then you know then i got
down for intro media gaming and then of
course i started doing the bgst thing
uh i was on multiplayer with uh with uh
next gen
and porter rock and all them and that
was wild
um then of course in in between all of
that
uh my boy xbox my boy xbox one boy
448k well i i mean we me and xbox 448
met in wii game here but we didn't talk
all that much
right and then in between all of that
like we started bonding more
gotcha and then he came to me about
uh an idea about him doing a podcast and
so like i'm still in kind of transition
of everything with intro media gaming
you know doing stuff with multiplayer
all this other different stuff and so
then
next thing you know um we do the next
podcast and it was me foolski's new uh
newark
uh you know saying there was supposed to
be another cat that was in there but
he he only showed up for one uh episode
and then
you know he had absolutely obligations
absolutely yeah yeah yeah
for the one episode um and then you know
we did and then the dawn you know i'm
saying so
it was me by in the dawn we were like
the
the the three headed monsters 108 would
say
about how about me 100 in him and um and
then so you know that's just kind of
that bond and me and bot's been
that's that's my dude right there you
know what i'm saying so shout out to the
next podcast man that's
that's how i came across you i saw it
yeah that was next
and then i think one of my first
appearances guest appearance shout out
to deal i think um
he invited me and yes that's the first
time i got podcasted which was was that
the dealer had me and you on rdx one
time
to get right back and do it's cool you
know
yeah yeah and so then we just and we
just kind of messed up into that and
then of course then
there was a falling out between me and
next gen you know
not getting into that crazy stuff but
you know i'm saying so i stepped away
from
multiplayer stepped away from bgst um
and then you know i started telling bot
that i was thinking about
starting my own podcast and this uh you
know of course there was support
and so you know and and big shout out to
these people too
for the help for me doing the doing
helping me with the discord j
sentries of course xbox don them helping
me out with the um
uh helping me out with just trying to
get everything together for the podcast
because i wanted to do game play and you
know
kind of be a bridge
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah that's our staple so and
you're just doing all that and then um
you know and just
the whole thing and then the one thing
about when we deal with grg the first
thing that i wanted to do was
um i i wanted to have female
representation but i wanted to have
a female of color representation
perspective
so the first person i went to was
delilah
i sit there and i hit up her i hit up a
video i seen her videos talking about
scale bound
and i said um i said i said you know
saying that and i hit him and
i said hey honey you know delilah he's
hey man yeah i know we talk all the time
i hit up delilah and i asked her about
it of course she was real reserved you
know i'm saying
and then she uh she was like i don't
know if people want to come up said nah
man you just way too talented you got
you got all the chops all the skills to
do this and i need somebody like you
that's grounded
that can help me because i know i could
be a damn nut so it's like
you know so and so we did so i hit up
her
um all day was also a part of something
i meant all day through b
shadows okay and so he was down for
being a part of it and then he
introduced me to fonzarelli
the building yeah yeah everybody talked
about the building yeah
right and then uh also um lady infamous
was part of intro media gaming
with us and so i i was like look that's
that's the second person she's
she's she's she's gamer she's about it
she's a little different but she
she's she's cool with what with her
delivery and everything like that and so
i promised i said we're going to make
this work i said you know look
at the very beginning of if you see the
very first episode of grg was a hot mess
the internet was going bad
at the beginning it was awful it was
awful i was like god there's people
still coming back i said i'm fine
but but we just uh evolved evolved
involved and then i cannot be more happy
if uh
looking at what all day is doing out
there with luca for what
bonzarelli is doing out there with with
the
with uh women at gwg what they're doing
out there
um for you know triple cub chuck for
what he's doing for what what hundreds
doing for what 108 is doing i mean it's
like
uh for for everybody that's been a part
of you know kaleidoscope that was there
for a short time at grg
you know for everybody who's been a part
of that is still i still look at him as
part of a family you know even though
you know i don't communicate with
everybody like i like i used to
yeah the thing of it is is that you know
i
i couldn't have that without that
factory yeah and and and that's the
thing of it is it's there's always going
to be love there
and and respect and it's always going to
be love and salute for everybody who's
gave me an opportunity that's even going
to next gen that's going
to uh anchorman v b shadows all these
guys without you know and we came here
all of y'all because
it's it's it gave me the inspiration to
do this and now since i'm married and
and the woman that i'm with now she is
the utmost just just like you know you
know she's like don't you gotta do this
iron lord's podcast
i was like oh okay i'm getting worried
i was like didn't even remember the time
zone
shout out to everybody out there man the
support the love the
you know for everybody who's had me on
their podcast and as a king thrash
and and you know what i'm saying i was
just on uh big clouds
gaming's uh podcast just uh friday night
and so you know
yeah yeah so it's it's just one of those
things man you just look at it and
and you know i i hope that
i always wanted to do what you guys do
you know what i'm saying it's just it's
bridge to gap bring this that's why when
i told you
and i think i told king david i was like
look i think this is how
it's supposed to be what i'm saying the
networking everything that what you guys
do
is proper it's legit and you know i i
can't be more proud of you guys for what
the hell that y'all do
yo you came moving to the house to the
compound
oh lord jesus oh man
shout out to my boy
[Laughter]
you bloody what it is it's like when we
go out there
we're not thinking you know for
ourselves first of all we game plan for
whatever convention we're going to
but we all try to get a place that's
accommodating enough for
local youtubers and stuff like that
people that we converse with
so when they come over we come over we
can politic
dead and playing dead as a unit because
if we collab with you we talk with you
we really vibe with you our doors open
let's build let's see where we can go
with this let's see how far we can take
this
let's see what what can change how can
we
put our imprint on this youtube on this
on our hobby on our love i would select
the medium
so how can we do it so um i
i truly appreciate the fact that you
came all the way out to calabasas
because he wasn't a few 100
still talks about that man to this day
hey man that was a long ass way man
they could be one of the few to actually
come that far to see it bro
yeah bro and then and then one more
thing i do want to say this before you
i got to give a shout out to the rest of
the crew you know what i'm saying if
people out here don't know about them pk
live
yes um six layer yeah of course bloody
knuckles
and operations op i know that those guys
they
don't come in as much as they they do
because they got other priorities and
stuff like that but
if you guys want to give people like i
like um
my boy pk and and six layer are walking
like like computers like those dudes
his audio video was crazy yeah yeah bro
well
yeah yeah crazy and just like what don't
wait 108 is just voice first and
yo yo but but he's intelligent as hell
he's like yo
yo there's no tv there's no tv
that's him
absolutely not tremendous but much love
to everybody from
muslims that's their presence try to
give you love delilah giving you love
on
yeah he said respect k mega got my start
with gaming podcast
on grg with you thank you and giving him
a voice on the show
so that was let's call it let's get this
super chat real quick before we move on
yeah we got 108 with the 10 super chat
halo is king i was playing online four
players split screen
using my uh using my with a program
called xbox connect
with about 20 dudes at the crib shout
out to sick and mini me
um yeah i remember excellent kai when we
started using extra kind of
yeah yeah addict get your mic bro
then we got one away dragons again two
thousand we had my 400 is the realest
shout out to race tracing
racing rachel ray's trace
um and so we've got a couple added right
now
we got simon brandy with the five pound
super chat the ps5 power narrative
reminds me of 2013. i hope xbox fixed
the situation before it's too late
you guys think digital foundry are bad
for gaming wow
you know what i think the foundry is
fantastic for gaming
it keeps it forces people to keep they
um keep themselves on their toes
and put their product out but again and
i know
y'all gonna say you'll keep me you
apologize man you sidestepping for xbox
man
the sdks bro i can't stress it enough
you got old technology with good sdks or
you got new technology with bad sdks
what do you want
you could be hot in the beginning but
brother this is a marathon this is not a
sprint
so when your boy fizzle out in the
middle and you're looking for some water
and my other running past i'm doing the
other stuff
you'll figure it out you know so right
about now this is very early on they
only been out for like a month
bro calm down so good man
are we all caught up sir yeah we're good
good man so look like i said tremendous
history brother
i love to hear these stories love to see
how everyone's connected in gaming
it's like a lot of crossover so that's
really cool but i gotta ask you the
question
we asked all the guests in the realm
before we get up into this joint
i need that top five video games or
franchises
of all time from kpmg let's go all right
uh
shout out to livewire too how could i
forget the king of the dolphins man i
can't
i cannot do that uh but um all right top
five
um okay so
um games or franchises you're personal
all right so let's go with uh let's go
with games um
okay so
[Music]
um this is no particular order okay uh
killer instinct
um killer instinct is up there of course
tekken
um you know what i'm saying um
but there's definitely uh uh the witcher
um
the whole franchise you know um for me
but
yeah but the witcher is definitely up
there mass effect
man one more uh and there's just so many
golly
um
probably going to have to say and this
is probably going to shock people
um i'm probably going to have to say um
dang well hold on hold on dang it no
because i can't i can't
i cannot i cannot i cannot i cannot say
halo is different
looking at you they like your way hey
yeah yeah halo's there like
i i gotta have halo there cause i was
gonna say i was gonna i was gonna say
final fantasy but yeah but yeah but but
it's got to be halo halo's got to be in
the top row
and favorite console of all time any
generation
playstation one
me and you p.s
i love playstation one i know everybody
loves two i mean you share that you
don't say
sure yeah but that no that's dope man
tremendous history man man wow
crazy we could talk came back this could
be a whole separate show
bro bro yeah jesus we got to move on we
got to move on man let's get these poll
results on
in the people have spoken with the
latest interview by phil spencer
discussing his disdain for console
tribalism
how do you feel in regards to its place
in gaming the winner of the three-way
ilp
poll at 63 percent of the vote is
competition
is good except for personal attacks
coming in at second place at 19 percent
of the vote was i don't care
i'm not for all this losing kumbaya
including that last place with 60 of the
vote which is okay to have pride in your
preferred platform group shout out to
all the lords who participated lord saw
what do you think about that sir
i mean yeah of course like listen man
you can love what you want to love
i'm not knocking anybody for loving what
they want to love now when it bothers
you that somebody else loves something
else you need jesus in your life you
need something in your life
for real like it's just i'm too damn old
to be having
strong opinions about video games
yeah i'm
we got to get into it man a lot of topic
but we got to move on so let's stop this
is you man
this one shocked the nation um
lots going on in bioware man what is
going on
so it was announced earlier this week
that uh
general manager to uh of bioware casey
hudson after having returned to the uh
return to bioware uh just three years
ago
uh has decided to walk away from the
studio once again
in addition to executive producer mark
dara who's also leaving uh
at the same time um so
a lot of people's reactions to this were
oh my god bioware's done
like a lot of reactions and i don't know
if that's hyperbolic i don't know if
if it's fair to think that way um
i i'd love to hear what you guys have to
say about it for me personally
it doesn't it doesn't sound good it just
doesn't sound good the way
you know the way they said things about
walking away to let the next generation
take over
um they sort of made it seem like they
left like they they came in to sort of
right the ship and then
they're letting them to do you know go
about their business now and they think
everything is
on the right track i don't necessarily
believe that
so man it's it's crazy it's really crazy
to see this happening i really do
feel that there is there is a big
disconnect between
what creatively the people
in charge of that studio want to do and
what
they're being sort of pushed to do um
and in addition to whatever creative
differences there are about where these
franchises need to go dragon age
mass effect i just think there's they're
just not on the same page
in any way shape or form and i think the
end products
hopefully don't show it but i i don't
have a lot of faith
yeah so real quick with frame before we
get the rest of the lawns in it so
pretty much ea announced what casey
hudson
executive producer of dragon age
certainly they both departed
um all ongoing projects including anthem
next dragon age and mass effects
legendary remasters will continue
they said samantha ryan will continue to
oversee the studio while christian daly
who joined bioware from blizzard
will now be leading dragon danger
product and then matthew goldman will
remain as uh creative director
and the mass effect collection will
continue to be led by
mike gamble and then looks like uh this
let laura miley from she's the chief
studio officer at uh
studios officer at electronics pretty
much said she wants to thank casey and
mark for everything they've done for the
bioware community
particularly our players they will
always be an essential part of the
studio's history
we appreciate their contributions and we
look forward to seeing what they will do
next so it looks like a simultaneous
departure
from both of them you know what i'm
saying which has got every so king wants
to go for i'm gonna get bigger but let
me get king for whatever reason it's
bubbling
you know saying it's a king what do you
have to say sir
it's doom and gloom
[Laughter]
it's moving blue run for the hills
i remember when you was like casey hurst
is back he's going to fix the world
casey hudson got over there was like boy
[Laughter]
and then it's like yo it's literally
like
he said nah i'ma step aside let the next
generation do this because they're out
of control
you know what i think that i think
they're
i think they're going to make their own
studio like usually when you leave with
with management like that is for a big
reason they left together they didn't
leave individually
yeah because they sat in the break room
together and looked at each other and
was like why are we doing this over here
i wouldn't be surprised and it was like
i wouldn't be surprised that they showed
up at another publisher or something
with their own studio in six months
with a real game with real like with a
real one
what happens if they show up at
microsoft what about that didn't um damn
i wish slow was here he'd known um
was it solved what's his name one of the
integral guys on
mass effect i believe his name was drew
carpenter
microsoft for a while they got their own
studio now and there's a lot of those
ex-bioware guys from the gen i mean from
what we like and they form their own
it'd be interesting to see
what's going on there as well but you're
never you're never going to get a mass
effect or dragon age how it used to be
with the
influence of va and that's just how it
is
i think the biggest problem i i believe
that they was like are we doing dragon
ages like
please put loot boxes
like what i want when you power up to
put a loot box
so put a little box in there's like yo i
don't see how loot boxing works over
here
and he's like but we must have loot box
but
this is how it is ea is like he's like
we want loot boxes in it this isn't a
loot box type of game
make it one it kind of reminds me of
that that that thing on friday where
smokey's like
is his mom wants some good cigarettes
he's like it's a dollar
six six
big big news in the industry bioware
storage history
we know about the franchise it's like
what is your feeling when you heard
about these departures man uh it's
it's not a good look um you know i said
the same thing about
with all these developers that left
naughty dog
and it's it's looking like it's the same
thing that's happening over here with um
with bioware and even though they got
christian daily that came over from
blizzard to come and help and take over
it's still all about chemistry all these
people have been there
for all the things for all this time i
mean i believe one of the gentlemen has
been there since what the late 90s
sometimes so it's one of those things
where you know
they they've they've came to this point
to where
you know like king david said the you
know ea is trying to go another
direction with their single player
experiences and now
um they i think they still want to kind
of keep the old traditional
style but i think you know this is
conflict
and when you have conflict it's crazy
and wasn't there something going on
where people were
once the other guy left that they had
that there was people that were speaking
out and saying that he was a terrible
manager and all that so
yeah and you know that's never good
that's never good that's never good
so you know i got i got
to jump in okay i'll be i'll get right
back to you okay is that um
you know mark dara um he
he put out his his statement right and
then what was this i don't know if you
guys played dragon's day there was a
character that was uh called cullen and
the voice actor
who played cullen had some things to say
on your men's way out and
i believe it's i've got the guy's name
but i have the quote and he was just
pretty much saying like
so you know obviously he said it's been
sad martial is like sad for him
you know moving on yada yada and then
your man is like oh and this is a relief
for many others
he was like i've worked with you for
over 10 years as the voice of cullen and
dragon age and have never worked with a
more disloyal
duplicitous corporate fake your
he said you're enforced resignation
is a victory for bioware it's employees
and
particularly the fans bro
you know you know what that probably is
don't you what'd you do
that that dude was completely
drinking the ea juice and he wasn't
fighting over it at all
because if you notice it like other
studios like um
the like respawn like like he's like nah
that didn't happen he fought them back
over it right
and i think a lot of these other studios
are so like they've been with ea
so long and they're so used to the ea
right that they they don't
they don't have no fight back they're
okay we'll do it all right we'll do that
all right we'll do this like
all i know is like i said this this idea
made these comments now now
dara did shoot back you know what i'm
saying they definitely shoot back
basically something like okay we're like
coming from you that that's kind of
disrespectful whatever
but to the most part the the fan base
was defending dara like
that we needed to borrow 30 dollars
though that's right
right facts i don't know what's going on
you know
i want to give it back to cape men
because i had to mention that that was
something that really
caught my eye like or this guy's kind of
resigning
you would think it's you know but she's
the best that kind of thing and he did
not feel that way but back to you
well i mean it's just kind of like what
king is saying is that dude is over here
now he's no longer
you know handing out paychecks now he
wants to talk because before then he
wasn't i mean if he felt like that dude
was that much
you know listen if you got that type of
problem with somebody you would think
you know man-to-man you know
person-to-person that you would address
that
not not out in public but you would
least dr address
that uh before like look man i mean i
think that there's some
issues internally i think we need to
work out and patch it out
if you can't have that communication and
then you try to throw salt afterwards i
don't know that looks a little shaky to
me
right uh but it also just kind of shows
right now that they're
it that bioware isn't dysfunctional
right and and and it
does kind of lead down the path of what
do we have
now since we have you know the people
that that were that were part of
what mass effect the great mass effect
and then when you had the new team work
on andromeda which you didn't get
received very well
i mean what is going to happen in the
future for for bioware it's it's pretty
it's pretty um it's it's one of those
things where we just got to have
wait and see but i guarantee you if they
have another
fail and i know i kept hard i i mean i
was on here and i was talking about
anthem you know i got still left shout
out to anthony
[Music]
the attacking that happened to me over
that game when that game flopped
i was happy i was done i was like i was
like sir is people
right like i was to the point where it
was solid it just didn't have the
concept
it's solidly in the ground man that's
the only thing
but that's that's the overall point
though to me is that like if they cannot
afford
another anthem they cannot afford
another andromeda so
whatever so so the next game says coming
from bioware
has to be right and if let's just say
that this 2.0 that they said that they
were still working on
please lord please uh for anthem if that
fails then i think that you were going
to see um
bioware dissolve and maybe uh get kicked
get the boot you know what i'm saying
take it take it take it out man solve it
i'll jump in
yeah we have uh a lot king one supreme
we have king of three two dollar super
chat
phil needs to throw that bag at casey
yeah
um then we got lord farms to ground the
game with two dollars
talk that talk king
that we have strong kingdom with the two
dollar super chat in my opinion
uh bioware hasn't been bioware since
mass effect 2.
yeah that's that's a valid yeah this is
true
that's valid yeah then we have victor
allison in two dollars super chat
it'd be great if they showed up at 343.
not to me yeah 343 could use that they
could use just about anything
then we have a slow mo with the five
dollar super chat drew carperson
is doing a sci-fi rpg with archetype
entertainment
yes they are expired where devs wouldn't
surprise me if dara joins laidlaw
yes yellow brick that's the same thing i
wouldn't be surprised if we've seen
some of those guys either casey those
guys know over archetype i would be
surprised
if you go quickly to carpenton's uh wiki
wikipedia page he says
um carpenter said that while his
interest in video game development waned
as bioware has changed over the years
my passion has been rekindled the feel
in the studio reminds me of early days
of bioware
i can feel the magic in the air
and it goes from another point like
regardless of what's going on over there
you know there's dysfunction over there
yes yeah
yes and then another thing too didn't
phil work with uh
work with one of the gentlemen there
when they when he was working on jay
uh jade empire i believe the
bad part isn't even that they left the
bad part is they left twice
basically left twice yeah that's the
fact that the bad part is also two
people to me two people let me jump in
if we ain't get this attraction
no i think we're good okay you're
missing
yeah get fourteen oh four yeah i don't
want to try that's right give me one
second
um we got gaming force hey with the five
dollar super chat
rib mass effect rfp dragon age maybe if
xbox bought them back in 2007 bioware
would be in a better state
i now have no expectations for bioware
yeah
i don't know to be honest fulfilled i
don't know i don't
i don't know where bioware would be and
i think and i think bill took over
fonza's point fonzes point is a right
gets right to it the grounding game with
two dollar super chat bioware will never
be the same under ea
to be honest with you like what if it
comes to that if if microsoft would
bought them like
i don't want a domino effect of them
buying uh bioware back in 2007
didn't end up to them buying obsidian
and i'm sorry but i i value obsidian
over over bioware so
i mean yeah that's that's absolutely
true sorry
that's cool um no this is weird like i
mean it's the first one it's saturday
because obviously these are two iconic
figures
from the studio you know i'm saying
casey we've done this obviously he left
the secretary fluff one time and he came
back and then they leave again
then to leave with mark at the same time
so now you've got
mass effects future drags nade's future
right
in in question and dan anthem right
that's what you know k megan's talking
about so it's like
you've got these three franchises that
now you know
what is really going to go on and to i
think dizzy said it in chat and i want
to i want to shout them out is that
look i know it's easy to blame ea
because we know ea track record i'm not
going to sit here and act like ea does
not have their hand on sabotaging a lot
of stuff
i think it's both for them equally in
disney defense i remember i don't know
if it was um
i mean it was angry jesus schreier or
one of those guys that came out
and they had those the leaks about what
was going on as far as
development and bioware and a lot of
this stuff was decisions that were made
by bioware as to why certain things
didn't work out so it did to me
it just never been a good marriage from
the start you know what i'm saying
what what people need to realize too is
like you conveying publishers
but there is such thing as called like
these developers get
really you know competitive with each
other and they see like destiny taking
off
right like they're like i could do that
better right and you know
then you know you have anthony yeah i
mean
this is such a dysfunctional thing it's
so much dysfunction and it's like
now you got this christian daily guy
like is anthem 2.0 gonna still
rock off the way and need to rock off
because they were gearing up for a big
reboot they're giving up for a really
you know to try to get some but but the
thing [ __ ] the big reboot
is just making it into destiny right and
we've already
shown that when you when you follow suit
with destiny
it doesn't work right this i'm gonna be
honest man i don't like destiny
but they could be only one right i
really don't think
the thing is there's no one ever yeah i
was wrong about destiny
i was way wrong about that the thing is
is none of these games truly try to
follow destiny they just try
they try to do the outlay and then say
and then do something different
and it's just like none of them ever
have pvp which clearly we've seen that
regardless if you don't like pvp or not
it is one of the factors that make
destiny what it is today
and no don't ever try it by the time the
division tried it it was too late
this is what i'm saying that this for
all by for everything that i've heard
about this sort of reboot of anthem
is just basically doing what destiny's
done right right
which they should have done from the
beginning and maybe they would have a
fighting chance but at the end
i still don't think so i really do think
that destiny
is at the point because you're you're
always going to be jumping in at the
beginning and you're going to be making
the mistakes that
destiny made six years ago now people
are not going to be accepting of that
right they're not when you have destiny
already i said that
beforehand yeah i said
we have a superior powerhouse in in
destiny
and we have an equal well not equal but
you know division is a powerhouse within
itself
or like you either or right
we don't remember does um
that game fit it doesn't anthem doesn't
fit right
okay it makes losing
sense we had an actual podcast that i
think we had they were skating
yeah this is like right around the debut
anthem division two was just announced
it was coming on strong it's had end
game
it was very serious and we were like yo
dusty's in trouble and
the guy i'll let you finish it because i
don't agree to solve i don't think that
like only there can only be one but i do
think that
the more this this market gets saturated
like
there can only be at least two to three
max right right and we're getting to the
point because
you know we talk about anthem we talk
about the division we talk about destiny
but there's still games like wars uh not
war zones uh there's still games
right yeah warframe there's still
these highly anticipated games that just
because we don't talk about them
they still hold a huge portion of this
of this
area addict there's a super chat wig for
you
oh someone is a a code
okay i guess i'll get it shout out talk
to ms cody you know this
me and this dude go back to back all the
time on twitter i've officially booted
him from the xbox community
merry christmas uh uh holiday deposit to
the iron bank oh yeah additives and
um is ambassading embarrassing
embarrassing
embarrassing i thought it said
embarrassing sony extremism is
banned from the xbox community never to
return
look man it's it's like that gift where
it's like it's hard at from
hey you can't get in you can't
you can't kick me from the gate optimus
code you got to get inside
you don't have no power here so you you
have to turn around and walk off
absolutely
shout out and much respect for putting
the big red stamp on it
to make sure that the race says yeah i
never i ain't never seen it
i thought what's going on
[Applause]
the town of green the city of green you
are no longer aware of the emerald city
you hold no
power here stupid to me
it's the situation it's just so
dysfunctional i i just
it's one of them situations we gonna
have to wait for that jason shrine
lord jason go ahead and dirt and we're
gonna see what happened because it's
it's to me it's one of two things it's
either
they are old and don't know what they
doing
right and ea is kind of pushing them out
the door
and you know some type of you know that
way or it's
so dysfunctional that they like your fam
you know maybe you could go over
x y z and we could do this thing the way
we wouldn't do it
so when you resign it's one thing to
resign
but when you reside with your man at the
same time
cool don't be skeptical but i find that
very suspect that y'all
like at the same time y'all both had
this epiphany it's time to leave
now like that means y'all went out that
board meeting right
and was like nah that ain't it that
ain't it
it was break room talk you know
with your man the sandwich you like you
feeling this
exactly what you want to do exactly and
i'm not bi
and i love both of them too but i'm not
buying this oh the franchise is going to
be in good hands
the direction is going to be you
wouldn't leave if it wasn't
if it was such a good heads you would
not be leaving fam right
and i got to keep the same energy i
don't respect the voice actor in being
as disrespectful wow as he was i mean
because i've never heard anything like
that
but wow you know they were forced out
the door
yeah a corporate dude now this is what i
say right
have to talk that talk when they're
there true yeah true that's why he
waited
until yeah that was a sucker move you're
right you're right you were there oh
yeah yeah that was yeah that was a chump
you don't hit nobody in the back of the
head while they walking out the door i
mean
first of all you face a man so i don't
respect it i don't respect former
employees talking bad about company
i don't respect uh people that uh talk
about people that left the company
if you couldn't say it when it was there
shut up because then you was that dude
that was smiling in his face
[Music]
you know so that that that that tells
you the integrity of the dude
they left the company and they said
nothing but nice things as they walked
away
you know he could have said yo and i
hate that voice actor dude but he didn't
you know so that that kind of bothered
me there
but i think those two like addicts said
might wind up either
someone's about to give them the back
yes regardless if they're going together
somewhere they're making
their own studio somewhere someone's
about to give them a back
yeah i'm going to be honest the only way
i feel that this this studio
survives under ea is to give the reigns
to vince
give the reigns events and let them
figure it out i think they're starting
that right now i think that that's where
they're
where they're actually aiming and that
could be one of the things while maybe
ea might be
in in the place to kind of push them out
because maybe there might be some
turmoil within
that space too if you think about it i
mean i don't know ea itself
overall seems like it's trying to right
re-insert itself to be something else
than than what we've known for ea being
in you you know what's crazy
to evolve is it is it respawn
didn't they take over another studio
right that's how he's about to
remember we always we commend events and
respawn since they've been there
they haven't been using they let's be
real they've been beaten to their own
drum even though they under the ea
banner
they've been using their own engine
they've really been using frostbite
they've been doing things how they want
to do it
and they've been proven successful over
there and dust vince has been given more
power
so what what if again i'm suspecting i
don't know that we're just speculating
well i mean just also add to this too is
the situation with
dice yeah i mean they they moved that
dude out the lead guy that was uh on
dyson i'm
and listen i'm a battlefield fan more
than i am a cod fan and
to me it's it's very imperative and
important for them to get
this next battlefield right you know but
when you go back and you look at who was
in charge when they had
when they had the best battlefield
battlefield three and four
you know that's you know when that
person is gone and this other person is
going to be taking over
are they going to fulfill the needs of
what gamers want especially if it's
going to be a modern or whatever
and i enjoy battlefield 5 but it still
isn't on the same level of what
battlefield 4
and 3 was so it's there's a lot of
moving cogs going around in ea right now
i have a feeling that there's a lot more
going with vance than we see
like to be honest with you i don't even
think he's controlling respawn anymore
i think that he's becoming that like
that that savior for ea like i really do
because
ever since he showed up things have
changed a little bit over there
i think he still has hands-on with
respawn but i don't think he's running
that studio anymore
i don't know like i think he's played
yeah
i think i think that you know if there's
a better comparison like with xbox
i think he's becoming the phil spencer
with ea like
i think he's start he's starting to to
control every one of their studios
because
it's it's it's it's crazy the the amount
of
what's what i'm looking for the
influence that he's having it was in a
short time
for them to give him that was it that
dice studio i believe
already you know and again i always
looked at it they beat
to their own drum like they did not
follow the ea template since they signed
up they were doing their
own thing and they've been proved
successful and it seems like ea is
leaving them alone
to continue to do whatever but we're
gonna see man this is this is crazy
you know one thing is he's a very
outspoken person too he's not like that
you know
listen this is the dude who told
activision you know what i'm saying like
he went to activision
he made the modern warfares that was
super lit from the beginning
you know what i'm saying he's like yeah
y'all not gonna take that credit from us
yeah i really do think that it was them
uh
dropping the bag completely when it came
to uh
putting out battlefield at the same time
as titanfall you know
it allowed him that leverage this is
like you're not doing this to me fox
this is this finish what you're saying
so no no i'm just saying that that
allowed him that leverage to be where he
is now because he's like you're not
doing this to me again
right you're not this is the same dude
that um
well when someone interviewed him
because when titanfall 2 first
like dropped and it flopped the way it
did they asked him
they asked him directly like how much
did ea help you he's like
because they said that they helped him a
lot he's like whatever if that means
like
he said that like he said that like and
keep in mind
like a year later they promoted him
vince
vince about the smoke you're not going
to talk about any old type of way he
don't care like so that i got a super
respect this you gotta get on the show
by the way
but yeah man at the end of the day we're
gonna see we're gonna see what's gonna
happen we're gonna see who
how this takeover is going on the rumor
is dragon age
is supposed to be shown at the game
awards or something like i'm hearing
things like apparent rumblings
we got a mass effect trilogy still
coming you know what and apparently our
game is still in development there
we got anthem 2.0 we're going to see
very quickly
you know come 2021 what's going on with
bioware and
obviously what's going on with these two
but look we gotta move on because we're
going stupid long
and we're gonna get this joint going so
um listen uh
this is kig this is you i believe there
was a forbes article
and um some things were said about uh
disappointments you know to elaborate
sir
okay so um you you're gonna frame it oh
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
i'll be out framing i mean pretty much
forget the gentleman's name um from
forbes um well it wasn't it wasn't taxi
shout out to taxi um
i ain't gonna say the gentleman but it
wasn't um at the end of the day you know
pretty much he the article's name is why
xbox series x is 2020's
biggest gaming disappointment he starts
to elaborate on some things
about what he feels you know um i guess
you know kind of
just being a better xbox one x um
and then he also did in the same token
in the if you read the audio did say
you know he feels kind of that way about
the playstation 5 as well that's just a
better version
of the thing and then um yeah he goes on
to you know talks about i guess
game charging controllers refinements
and then certain features that at the
time
you know weren't working as intent i
guess like quick resume and certain
things series xp so this was going
around
this is a hot button topic this week i
see king you grabbed it up so uh
what do you feeling okay well um i like
to say this right
uh these these consoles both of these
consoles going
forward aren't big uh drastic
differences
uh from the last consoles that they
replaced
right so i want to take the pro versions
of both consoles right
now if you look at the xbox one x
that console was pretty much perfect
the only problems was the jaguar calls
and
the the jaguar cores and the um hd
uh the hard drive right so now that you
move to
ssd you upgrade uh the memory and you
upgrade the gpus
and you have the same user interface see
this is where the huge problem comes in
from anyone that purchases a series x or
series s
they look at the x series um i mean the
xbox
one x and the interface didn't change
right so you know when you get something
new
like a television you don't want to turn
in the new television and it has the
same interface as the last one from
perspective
you want to feel different you want to
be lied to right so okay
what microsoft did was they perfected
the user interface because they saw the
fiasco of
going from the 360 to the one
and the problems that it had it didn't
have certain things
what microsoft wanted was as soon as you
start
everything works right you see the
problem with the playstation 5 right now
they don't have all the same things and
all uh
the same functionalities as the
playstation 4's user interface
people are having certain problems right
now and they're just you know you know
cutting their teeth on things microsoft
is not having those problems
they refine the user interface now on to
the controllers
the only thing that people are saying
that is next-gen
besides the look of the playstation 5
which is a drastic look you know
somebody walks in your house they say
they're like oh my god where's that
stink
yeah it's very very distinct you know
the white and the black is like wow
what's that in the blue
and you go see the x you probably won't
even notice it in the corner
but that's purposeful right right now
you go to the controllers
the xbox one you know controller was
pretty much perfect
they evolved certain things on it to
make it
actually probably the best controller
ever made right now
with the reducing of latency the
controller nubs
the the grips the small grips on the
back they really didn't have to change
too much
my biggest barrier with the playstation
to be honest with you was the controller
what the playstation 5 controller is so
much better
it feels next gen and then they give you
little things like the rumbles that we
already have adapted triggers
we already have that stuff but they have
that so that's next-gen
that's what they feel like is next gen
neither one
console i can say feels like that leap
forward when you went from dreamcast
from saturn or you went from playstation
uh three from playstation 2. you know
we are used to giant leaps in technology
and we're not getting that now but they
are
leaps right speed my biggest problem
with the playstation 4 was the speed of
the console like damn it man
why do i always gotta wait for this and
i move out of here and i'm so used to
the snappiness of the xbox
now i don't have that problem no more
it's more tolerable over there
the same thing with the xbox i go from
one game
to quick resume is ridiculous it's the
greatest thing about play control
i stop my game where i'm at and i just
leave it turn off my console
i go to the store and i come back and i
can go upstairs
and it resumes upstairs to where i was
at yeah you understand how so off that's
going to be
again it's different feelings so i feel
his uh concern plus there's no
software the the playstation has
software as far as demon souls
and a couple of other games that makes
it look like it's taking advantage
of next gen right these dudes don't have
the televisions as
well for the and that's the console
problem right now before you can take
your console and put it up to your tv
and be like wow that's nice
no brother not now now you have to
change your entertainment set to fit
you know dolby atmos do you have a
surround sound with dolby atmos
television that can do 120 hertz you
have
certain things right to maximize this
stuff
so what i'm saying here is has has this
been a disappointment to you guys
because i see the technical achievements
both consoles have made
but to categorize it and this is
clickbait because it seems like anytime
you put microsoft under a gun
everybody's gonna run to your post and
they're gonna say
oh yeah man i'm down with that it's like
this this um i see it by the media
the narrative is bash xbox at every turn
that they can possibly do
they do something wrong anywhere it's
bash xbox but both of them are doing the
same thing
title is the playstation 5 the biggest
disappointment
right so your contention is that it
both consoles kind of should fall into
this category as opposed to just the
xbox being labeled
right because it's buried in the lead
when you read the
the the the story and he does mention
when you do
i will give you that when you actually
read his article he actually
references the playstation in the same
light yet
we saw what the title was but let's go
and read the article they just read the
title i know that that's a fact that's a
fact that's a fact let's get kay back in
man i know if you saw this article
you know what you're feeling on this
whole thing is it are you disappointed
okay megan
absolutely not i think that this console
is absolutely amazing
um i and i'm and i'm looking at it from
from this perspective because the thing
of it is is the game aspect
um and this is where i i totally
disagree
and i think that people just kind of
fall into this eco chamber of
of just you know you hear so much
negative stuff about xbox this xbox that
and that people just kind of feed into
it when they see an article or they read
something and it's
in in really what it's based upon to me
is like when you talk about the launch
playstation's launch is decent i mean i
mean you go back and you're thinking
probably about the
the best launch that probably
playstation ever had and that was
i don't know maybe the playstation 2
with tekken tag and um
and the bouncer and then and some other
games on that top of that but
i mean you got demon souls you got
spiderman those are good titles but i
mean
what people are talking about when they
bring this up is saying like oh well
xbox don't have any games to
to play on the you know on the series x
how do why do people even want to buy
that console
if that was the case then why did people
buy a playstation 4
you know because if we went by general
by the by
who would win the generation by by game
titles then the x
xbox one should have dominated right
because they had i mean when you got
dead rising three going against rezo gun
and killer instinct going against
killzone
and four to five going against um you
know
uh injustice gods among us the unlimited
edition
you see yeah you know you had rise and
you know you're saying
you had yeah like that that that was a
killer lineup
but the thing that overall messed up
xbox was the price
and the messaging so it and when people
buy
new products and this is and this is so
funny when people
in the console space they don't think
about it's electronic it's just no
different than a television or a car or
anything else
the only thing is about with consoles is
that you're guaranteed to have
some some some malfunctions it's just
you know
we're the beta testers right so the
thing to me is like
you we buy these consoles because we are
the hardcore
we want the newest and the best things
that we can get our hands on
that's that's what it's always been
about it's not about
the games matter but it's about the
technology in these new boxes is why
people go and gravitate to them
right and and then that's and then for
the casual market they
they can only care about just wanting to
be a part of it later on or find the
cheaper
the cheaper version of it but the
hardcore always is going to
buy the next the next do appliance or
the next new
you know whatever and that's there's no
difference there so i think when you say
that it's a disappointment
i just have to laugh at that because
even if you look at the playstation fan
that
has what they have even if they had an
uh uh playstation five that was
defective
i guarantee you that they're trying to
get another
playstation five because they're excited
about their console
just be excited about it that the
clickbait stuff has gotten
really tired in my opinion and i think
we just need to to move on and evolve
from that i'll feed you about this game
and meet up we got to move on out for
you brother
so i'm going to get the super chat let's
get at it all right cool
um we have ever born saga with the 5
super chat a little cognito this is not
a drill i'm at costco and yonkers and
they have the sonos arc in black
about to cancel that best budget oh my
goodness i'm about to send you that
bread oh
been playing musical chairs for a while
now that is true um
but hopefully now he just figures out
what he wants to do on his own
um the living flame with the 5 super
chat i generally believe the revamp for
anthem is all it's going to get
and they'll focus on the stuff on dragon
age and mass effect
rest in peace anthem wish d2 was good
right
all right then we have victor allison
with two dollar super chat i think
anthem's third person game play was
solid
um then we have jonathan b with the 10
super chat i believe i belong in the
bushes i haven't had my series
since day one and i just figured out
that i needed to switch the refresh rate
to 120 hertz 4k
in the console settings my life is
forever changing
i know he was like what the hell
how are you going to upgrade me what's
the higher than number one that's how i
feel about the xbox ui the book of
x all right then we got mods
i'm just gonna say ten dollars super
chat video this morning
shout out to bob's pulling in the
building stand up loads of gaming down
there stand up
no doubt 60 fps series x and ps5
delivers that now
i'm happy
all right i know you got much time left
but i want to get you you're feeling
right
is it a disappointment sir
uh yes
[Laughter]
i'm just i'm just gonna keep my opinions
no i'm saying you're disappointed
microsoft execs are listening and anyone
is listening sony execs are listening
they want to hear from you they want to
hear what is your disappointment
they don't need smoke blowing and they
button they don't need
it's disappointing it is but you know it
is what it is
i i i am moving forward from now on i'm
not
gonna continue to go over exactly
why you're disappointed yeah what are
you disappointed with
i'm not i'm not going to do it i'm not
going into it man i gotta go i gotta go
i gotta go to work
don't i gotta go to work i've been here
i've been here ten minutes too long man
i gotta go
you working on trying to get a job at
microsoft
well i'll make it easy for is it is it
more the lack of the software stuff
is it the um the the features like just
if you have to nail one thing because of
the first party software offering and
the halo not being there
it's just i personally feel like you
know
in terms of them claiming power
right we just didn't see that and it's
like i get it like i
i understand that they're behind when it
comes to
you know the deaf kids but at the end of
the day that's not my problem
actually i feel that you if if you knew
you're going to be that far behind
on these well you know on the on the dev
kits and
uh these certain devs you should have at
least made sure that the people
that are making the third parties for
the games is coming out when the console
comes out
right should have been where it should
have been there's no reason why all
these games and you know people says
you know power matters it's just power
doesn't matter when it's not taken
advantage of
and that's microsoft's fault for not
making sure it's taken advantage of
regardless if it's the regardless of if
it's the lack of dev kits or it's not
the lack of dev kits
it was microsoft that gloated this power
and it was microsoft to let the power
get
swept away in a matter of couple games
sure that's probably going to change in
in the matter of six months to a year
but guess what in six months to a year
you can lose an entire generation and
your feeling is to your point
right again god speak your mind brother
is no one wants to hear it
right at the end how how how long have
we been hearing it right
i get it we heard the entire xbox one x
legit
and i get it but i understand your
sentiment your sentiment is like look
i bought this i don't really want to
hear about kids tools and
where's it at and i i feel you so that
is
i say a lot of people in the community
wanted them to buy time exclusives now
i'm not for that
i would i think you should have really
you know
evolved try to do as much as you can
like in a third party on game pass
scenario if you could have
right but you know once halo got delayed
i don't know if there's enough time for
that
but it's just like look like i would
prefer them to not
buy timed exclusives of of investing
into other studios to help build their
portfolios
and then they don't want to make sequels
to those portfolios so it's just like
i would prefer them to take that money
and run it through their ecosystem
and make their games better than to
spend 500 million dollars
on getting a timed exclusive for a
couple games to count i just got to ask
you about though you got to go what
about
when you say things like that what about
with the bethesda announcement the cmax
announcement does not not give you
confidence to say look they're investing
in their own brand
that they are really trying to address
that issue
see and that's what i was saying i would
want them to invest in their own
portfolio
than just going to bethesda and be like
yo uh you know we
we want uh you know that death loop you
know we saw that sony has that
he's like okay you got anything else for
us like can we get some timed exclusives
they didn't do that they said yo we want
to buy the whole thing
it's it's like we tired of this losing
time it's like you know kids moves
always said like
if they make these bethesda games
multiply it's a complete l because your
competition doesn't care that you're
that your consumers don't get these
games your competition's going out and
making sure
that the final fantasy 7's are exclusive
making sure that the 16s are exclusive
they're making sure that the the death
loops and whatever that other game's
exclusive
and if you're not doing that with your
own games
yeah you like this better be locked out
or else there's problems
yeah yeah i mean when you seen sony that
just went ahead and they
they locked down spiderman on the event
one of them
yeah i'm all in support of of trying
of having gaming you know we don't have
to do the console war garbage but
right xbox do have to solidify
and keep their games in-house uh for
their
gamers when it comes to it i enjoyed the
series x i enjoyed what i played for
kids be making fun of me because i'm
playing star renegades and attack on
titan 2 on it
and i'm like like i play games i want to
play it it's just like look like
you know i came from the xbox one s i
didn't come from it
factually and it's just like these games
run way better
and i would i never make that i'll never
make it 4k hdr now so it's like i'll
never make that error again because
these games are they might be runnable
on the other platform
but i got tired of people that didn't
have these platforms
making statements about these platforms
in fact you you would always give us the
xbox
one s perspective
way more games it was pretty much like
oh does this
can you press start and go to the main
menu ship
it it's done make sure that's on the ass
yo i love the fact that i can't bother
you no more yeah
yeah you can't call him a layman anymore
the xbox was simple
talking about he had the smart tv i
can't talk to him talking about
oh you have the lowest spec your boy is
running around
4k and he's running around here with the
high expect xbox
last thing for my boy i had to go for it
i know we got to go to work i know he's
late
what about tuesday this tuesday does the
turn around having your favorite game
is about to get that optimization and
that that's cute and everything
wow it's about to life
oh so you're not gonna play all right
i'll be playing no i'm gonna
can you let me talk you asked me a
question and you keep interrupting me
i'm saying the perspective of getting
this expansion on your platform making
sure it's on game pass ultimate
oh yeah the stuff that takes advantage
of your next gen hardware yeah that's
next month that's not this month
like no it should have been on launch it
should have been there
when the expansion was hot because guess
what i had to do
i had to buy it on pc and play for a
month on pc
like i said you ain't saying nothing i
don't agree with all i'm saying is
at the end of the day now that it's
coming are you going to put your fitness
there
and and protest and not play it i never
said i'm protesting i just gave my
opinion that it should have been their
day one
absolutely we hear you and we also see
out of everyone here i am the one that
leads destiny from time to time
i get it it's fine brother all i'm
saying is
everything you said is valid also in
reference to what's going on we
we also have to acknowledge and this is
both consoles not just xbox
we also have to acknowledge that these
systems are being launched
in a unique scenario we are in the midst
of a pandemic yeah there's uniquely
nothing to play on the xbox clearly
clearly and you're upset and you're
upset i feel you you know i'm just
saying
i i cannot not acknowledge that when
that is
don't get me wrong they ain't nothing to
play on a playstation either there's
demon souls that's all
right like but it's just like you did in
five hours
you already got people you already got
people that was over there on
on playstation like lucas i don't know
what to play anymore on playstation
because
she know it like rand even said this i
think it was random that said that not
luca like
like th this this oh this is amazing
these plays they know that that's
temporarily
there is nothing to play out outside of
demon so guess what you're going to play
outside of demon's souls you're going to
play the same stuff we playing on with
xbox
you know i feel like that boss morale is
that astro astrobot
it was another box robot looks good uh
good i actually do want to try that when
i get a playstation
that's like the only i mean the
spiderman i didn't i wasn't a fan of
2018. milo seems like a better character
than the 2018 spider-man i played
but it's just like it's not worth
playing a whole console for a dlc
well you don't play you don't play them
long enough
well listen i played that game very
thoroughly uh sir
and i would definitely say this he's a
simp i'm not down
oh yeah i was making fun of the fact
that i was like hey man is that how you
dudes in brooklyn out there oh my god
[Laughter]
i'm talking about exactly what that man
was i'm sorry
that first spider-man he he plays like a
man he was doing man things
and he controlled it in a man's place i
know this is a child
right i'm not saying that i i don't know
as a child but
simp life that you get beat up and doing
all that stuff
i'm not gonna spoil it for a lot of you
who didn't get a playstation i know it's
a soft launch and i know in february
but um listen man
i could have dealt with it more if he
was 13 right whether 13 he's
17 years old and with the new character
model it looks like he's older than the
the
the spider-man character
the same size as this what what are you
trying to say here like
that but oh sorry switch out that you
and then me all
[Music]
we have the living flame with the five
dollar super chat to addict's point i
feel lied to since phil said did say in
december developers were already
making games on series x at the vgas
just
fix it already and then we have gaming
forte with the ten dollars which
i can't be disappointed i got what i
wanted from a console they delivered
uh that expectation for me if i want to
play on the most powerful platform i
would play on pc i have my friends and
destin
yeah um
make it make sense when do you see full
power from a game console in this first
year people sound dumb with cover 19
please stop it it's true people forget
about that like you know
it's because again social media makes it
so everybody has a voice
and sometimes dumb people talk a lot
[Laughter]
and it's like you know and it becomes
the problem is that those narratives
become truth to some people
mm-hmm and then here we are discussing
it um we have persian knight with the 20
super chat xbox makes bold claims and
then reel and reels them back in
look at the newest initiative rumors
keep expectations and check et cetera et
cetera
i'm just tired of it how is microsoft
going to go up against ratchet and
horizon 21
with halo and when valid points i mean i
can understand the frustration you know
what i'm saying
in the spring watch your tone boy i know
i i'm like
halo's going to be guaranteed to make
his money i don't know about
that [ __ ] and clink yeah i don't know
what your mouth
is
all i can say is that oh i got jumped on
is that what my wife says what my wife
says
it's not normal for something skinny and
white the outperforming something big
and black out doesn't it
[Music]
i feel the same way about the ps5 in
regards to how little there is to play
but i sold my ps4 pro two years ago
so it feels great to experience games
like ghost institution at 60 frames per
second
look yeah soft get your joint off
because i know and then yeah let me
listen real quick um
even reading the entire article by the
end of the article he says look
it could be just me that i'm old and
jaded
and and and that is exactly where i sit
right
for me the most stressful part and kind
of exciting part of
of getting the new consoles is getting
the new consoles getting them in the
house
and starting to play them yes once once
you've had them
a week or two you sort of fall into your
routines with your consoles like you do
what you always do and it's it feels
kind of like old hat
um we will never like we've gotten to
the point where
we just as hardcore gamers you're you're
just gonna see diminishing returns on
certain things
right the transitions aren't going to be
as drastic and you're not going to be as
wild
we will never again see a super mario 64
moment we just won't
i don't think we ever will i mean i hope
i'm wrong but i
don't think that's the case so the fact
of the matter is
it's yeah exactly but but it's
again for the longest time we've seen
these incremental improvements right
now that said i don't find it to be
disappointing because
the console space from from one day to
the next right the moment you get your x
in your house the more you get your ps5
in the house
all of a sudden for the most part 60 fps
is kind of the norm right regardless so
that's a huge difference
that is the longest difference when you
factor in all the other stuff the vrr
um when you factor in games that are
that are you know already at 6k
something like that downstairs like 100
and another thing that came in
at the back end of all these narratives
leading into
launch is 120 fps nobody's
talking 120 fps until maybe like two
months before launching like really
this is the reality yeah is this a
reality
and for the most part the games that are
doing it are doing it like you know
this is not this is stuff that if you
had your x
or your ps4 pro or whatever in your
house
up until the day before you got your new
console the leap from one to the next
is is obvious right obviously
it's not disappointing in that regard um
i just think for me
i am that sort of older jaded dude that
is like
it's after the initial excitement a
couple of days
i just fall right back into the normal
neck in the chat
he said what was the first game you
played in series xsoft
the first game i played on my series x
was bright memory why everything else
installed
saluted egg bucks continue
yeah it's just fast you know what i mean
it ain't
they're the prettiest um but that's it
to me so disappointment yes
to say to say it that way it is very
click-baity it's just getting
you know just getting people there when
you read the full article he
acknowledges that
you know it's just not wowing me
right and i think what playstation has
done in terms of their marketing
is to to create that that illusion that
you're going to be super wild right and
when you have people talking about the
controller
and i'll be honest beyond astro every
implementation of the controller i've
i've i've
seen doesn't feel nearly as robust like
people are talking about the tension
uh when you see when you're swinging in
spider-man
i don't really notice it
i i don't notice those things so it's
really just astro to me anyway and i
heard call of duty
doing some things as well beyond that
like they just
they're better consoles and they're
bringing pc type performance into the
console space for the first time first
time that's what we should be excited
about everything else
bushels let's get the subject then i'll
go and then we gotta we got to move on
hold up hold on a second i gotta say
gerald mack i think we are there having
too much fun with k megan and his
story's back
man yeah i didn't i didn't sorry did
that win no no no no no
no we have gerald
with all the malfunctioning ps5 don't
understand
why that's not the biggest
disappointment for 2020 maybe i'm biased
book of x oh yeah maybe
maybe a little bit you are biased and
that's how you control the narrative
because
i notice a couple of dudes will talk
about oh xbox is running hot
but then when it's debunked and then the
playstation is running hotter
they don't come back behind it and say
nah but the playstation is really
running hot
or you know this and i just saw one dude
too long he took two weeks later
to report that call of duty was breaking
and bricking playstation fives
the same way they were breaking and
breaking um xbox series x
but you took two weeks to report that
but the first day that popped up on your
timeline
you made sure that the x was out there
so i'm telling you it's over season on
xbox
but spoon very soon
it's open season on this playstation and
i told you
this xbox will win this generation
phil gets to smoking no more jokes
you're taking your ex
your playstations to the store and
you're getting it next i already know
what's happening
it's gonna happen okay well i mean they
go they can go they're gonna get game
pads off of their tvs when they finally
eventually get rid of their old tv so
yeah you know
you want to go yeah we got slo-mo with
the five dollars of attack there comes a
point in time where you get tired of
being told to manage your expectations
let's try something new meet my
expectations is that too much
i agree you know what it was funny about
that though we've given microsoft a lot
of credit
uh for being transparent right um and
coming out and saying things when sony
was quiet
now the problem is that when you when
you talk a lot and at the end of the day
what you've said in the past doesn't
match with what's happening
and people people get mad right where
sony
didn't create any expectations and they
were quiet damn to the la
to the last month before launch they
were quiet and then
so then everything that they showed
without saying a peep
seems like oh my god right because they
don't they didn't say they didn't build
anything
and they just showed you and then it's
up to you to feel whether you're blown
away or not right
so i kind of want microsoft to kind of
just be quiet now
just do it they cannot do that
you have the luxury as being the
champion to shut up and let you
talk you know the challenger has to tell
you i'm gonna go in and i'm gonna knock
him out in the eighth round
i'm gonna go in there i'm gonna do this
the champion don't gotta say
anything because he is point proven
we're not gonna act like
god of war and sony didn't build a hell
of a resume
i respect only from the beginning i
stood out on those lines i know what
playstation one
and playstation 2 and playstation 3 did
not a fan of the playstation 4
but they got games on the playstation 4
that was outstanding right they
don't have to say a damn work it's up to
microsoft to talk
and walk that walk absolutely okay but
that's that's fantastic but what happens
to the person that walks the walk
and doesn't and talks to talk and then
doesn't walk the walk you know what
i believe that i believe this generation
is going to be different i really do
but let's say it takes them a year and a
half to two years it's not a year and a
half
no yeah you got you got to show and
prove right when you drop halo right
yeah that was the whole reason why they
did well
you know everybody think of the delay
you cannot you cannot come and do all
the talking and the next thing you know
it's it's well yeah let's just get let's
just wait till 2022 when you're really
going to see it
that will be yeah that will be the point
to where i think
even people like me will start second
guessing and even
that's unfair right because like king
said it's a marathon right
but they don't have the luxury of being
able to do that
sony could do that for two years and and
and this
and the faithful will be there ready for
when the bangers come
right right microsoft doesn't have that
luxury they just don't know
not this run not this time no when that
halo drop
it better be all that in the bag of
chips oh fashion
hashtag save lock man i'm telling you
than what y'all showed out there oh no
that's a factual man
yo i you know what i'm saying i got a
small rant just a small rant i got to
say this
please uh halo die hard fans you know
what i'm saying i'm a halo die hard fan
but the bungie
fans yes sir stop wishing for bungie to
come back and do
343's job let 343 do their job
we've seen what corey balrog did to
david jaffe's
god of war and a playstation fan you
have to give them credit because
they let they allowed it there may have
been speculation there may have been
hey man i don't know about this and then
but it worked out because corey balrog's
vision
worked let 343 uh industries have their
vision
let them make it work and and just see
what they can do instead of trying to
dictate
what you want i think once we get to
that point
then we can start we can stop talking
about 343 in their situations and all of
that i
you know halo 5 has got to deliver on
all fronts
i'm saying because the bungee fan of
halo
is is almost crippling and trying to
make it go backwards
i hope it don't i hope that they move
forward from that but we'll see
where we come from last week was what we
got uh so we got the wise little gamer
with the five dollar super chat
phil knew this this gen is going to have
uh diminishing returns
so props to playstation for putting in
tech into the controller to make it
to make something feel next-gen yeah i
mean
that's the first couple of days i was
like yeah and every time i play apps
robot i was like yeah
everything else though like even in
demon souls demonstrate they have this
stabbed like when when you stat when you
you can stab the enemy up front and then
you pick you pick them up and like drop
them down
you feel the rumble but it's not nothing
to the extent
what you feel with astrobot so it's like
in the midst of gameplay
i'm not even noticing it so it's one of
those things where it's like
after a week you get over it right
they're gonna take that stuff
out look man we going to shout out to
the medic 10 hour super chat shout out
to the medical talk team last night
remember sony's success
came from years before the games came
out their first party build up started
ps3 era
and paid off 2016 plus payoff for
microsoft won't be 2021 but 2022 and
beyond
look i get it i get it i get both sides
and me and you shout out to them
we've had this conversation we had an
intense little discord debate you know
shout out to him but i i hear where he's
coming from at the end of the day i see
both sides
you know there's gonna be some people
that say nah fam i'm tired of waiting
i'm tired of managing my expectations
and then for those people it's like yo
there's playstation then switch
go knock yourself out if you so unhappy
but for me
i look at it and i know okay megan look
at respect it's like i look at his
sports like
if you're not buying studios you're not
doing things
that show me that you care about the
future of your product and your
organization
then i would question when i see those
things i'm like nah
they in it to win it you know what i'm
saying it's just a matter of okay if you
want to stick around or not that's all
this is
it it's your patience as a game now if
you only have the xbox platform and you
frustrated i get it
but if you're a gamer you got everything
you got stuff to play so you you gucci
regardless at the end of the day
look to homies article i'll just make
real short
definitely clickbaity title you know i'm
saying i'm not going to dance around it
you know i'm saying at the end of the
day
because if you say that and then i read
your article and you actually say the
same thing
importation to the playstation in the
same article
then it takes away the weight of your
title in my opinion
all i will say is when i read it though
yeah a lot of the things he said were
valid like there's you know slight
improvements here
you know a refined more xbox one there i
can't get mad at the only problem i
seriously had with the article i've
respected it but the one thing i
i had was that he said he said a
sentence he's like of course no one in
their right mind will buy the series
that's because of consoles exclusive
that's playstation but he said it's
galling to see microsoft do little to
change its ways
that's the sentence i have a problem
because how can you say
it's going for them to have nothing to
do little to change his ways
when they when they started with eight
studios to sony 14
and now they have 23. it was three years
right
but let me talk about way back but i'm
talking about before what i'm saying so
my thing is
if i see someone acquire 23 studios
that is not they've done little to
change their ways
yeah that is addressing the issue that
people have
you know so that's my only beef with
dude you know i'm saying other than that
look you're not happy not happy nobody
unfortunately like it if you don't like
it
me you know what i'm like you know what
i like was that i like
they addressed the issue right you
brought uh zenimax right
right and it's like but will they put
their games on the playstation 5
right right why is this even a
conversation no
no it's not i just love the fact that
they addressed the issue they addressed
the problem right but
i'm going to let us eat over there
for where i come from if you spend that
money amount of money you know you're
trying to keep that in your ecosystem
especially if your game plan
is game pass pc x cloud mobile
that should be the market you shouldn't
have to rely
on any going to a multi-pla at that
point if you spend that money or
in my opinion you would make an ea deal
where the ea games still go over
to playstation but they're still but
they're in game pass or whatever kind of
thing
but this is not that little deal but
look we're going on we got to move on
crazy
i'm mine's my short this is gonna be
super quick it's about little man as
king calls him
little man little man we gotta talk
about the series that's a little man
so look um i'll make it quick um
obviously when it was announced 1440p
120 hertz almost same architecture
series x
you know for the person who is budget
conscious who does not care necessarily
about 4k you know this is the system for
them and for the most part like i said
you know they've been hitting the
targets and stuff like that the only
thing i have to bring to the realm
uh it's just been bothering me i gotta
bring this out there it's been bothering
me it's just that like
okay so we saw at first with valhalla
when the series it was 30 frames on the
series s at first i had a problem
in my i'm not a developer whatever i'm
like
how could they not do 60 and bring the
resolution down yo
that was just me right now eventually
that did get addressed right and now
shout out to my boy i forgot his name on
twitter oh man he showed me
the footage and i think kiss moon was
another one so now that is that
but y'all know i'm a big destiny fan now
i don't even have the series s
but when i saw the news about that 120
frames mode right
and i'm looking at all the platforms and
i saw one platform wasn't supported
and i'm like oh man why little baby got
that
you know what i'm saying so again and
i'm not trying to make a scene again
like i'm a developer
like it's so easy you know what i'm
saying obviously we know the whole thing
kits and tools and i'm not gonna get
into that all i'm saying is like
to me when you got dirt you got gears
five or the s running at 120.
you've got examples of these other games
running at 120 and all i'm asking for is
this crucible mode
to i just wouldn't like that party so
the thing i'm bringing to the realm like
do you think what's your thoughts on
this situation
you know what i'm saying is it a
situation where it's like yo they ain't
hitting these performance targets
because they can't
or is it a situation where it's like yo
they're treating it
they're worrying about the x first you
know what i'm saying and they treat like
it's like where are you
at with the series s and these
performance targets came back
uh i think it's a little bit of both i
think if you look at it that
both consoles i mean the devs with these
with all these they're spread thin like
i mean you got a you got the xbox one
stuff you have the xbox s right now you
have the
the uh the the series s got the series x
and you got pc then you got the switch
and then you got the playstation 4
you got you got the playstation slim you
got the pro and then you got the five
so i think they're just they're just war
they got too many things going on and
until some of these consoles
get discontinued i think that that's
going to be the problem
from third party where the s is going to
have to shine
is the first party right and that's
that's where you
where people can understand look i mean
this is where we uh this is this is
where we can show you that this this is
capable to have the power
we might not really get that with the
third party right now but it'll
eventually come
and i understand that some people might
say well that's not that's not cool but
other than that i you know i think
anybody who wants to invest into the s
anyway is only just wanting to get it
because of the value and with game pass
not so much of the person that
want to invest into the the latest best
televisions or monitors things like that
not for you okay i guess my frustration
just said for the fact that i look at
the innards and the specs for that
yeah no i i totally agree with you
people act in my opinion people acting
like this is some little
i'm like nah this joint is a beast if
you really look at it
you know it's a beast that's all but i
hear your point but so what do you think
man
yeah i really do think uh a lot of what
mega said is correct i just really do
think
when you have on the third party side
you have you know
ubisoft developing nine versions of a
title that's a good point
the s is going to fall to the wayside
simply because when you look at the
install basis of last gen
they're gonna continue to focus on
making a decent game
a decent playing and running game on
those machines for for the foreseeable
future
i don't really think it's going to be
quite some time before they just
completely up and walk away from that
stuff so the s
might find it's it's it's it's itself on
the wayside a little bit until it
becomes you know
the focus where it's it's just ps5
series x
and the s um and then with the s uh
it is also one of those things when it
comes to the perception of it
i do know i have heard that a lot of
streamers use it because it's a great
sort of machine just for streaming yeah
and you don't have to worry about the
high freight you know
that the resolution and stuff like that
but
um you know early on when when digital
foundry first got the
s they said one of the first things they
said is like this machine
is probably more of a 1080p machine than
a 1440 machine right
and i think for those people that were
looking for it to be a 1440p machine
uh to use on their on their pc monitor
or whatnot that can be disappointing
right so if you use it for that purpose
and you're not just a casual gamer
you're looking
for streaming or something like that and
it's not hitting those performance
targets i do think
yeah definitely you'll definitely be
disappointed by that but i do think
in terms of first party they're going to
do the best to maximize this machine
and the long term is just going to be is
going to be slower they're going to
focus on the big boy
and that that is for sure um but you
can't
under like for 300 this is a beast of a
machine absolutely absolutely
absolutely i just i really don't i
really want to see what you know
these these talk about like this this
lack of ram in the long term
what means for these big first party
games coming down the pipeline
you know that are going to look kind of
crazy on the x how are they going to
look and run on the s
and will it be something that's
comparable right and
by complement i mean hitting that 60 fps
target if you hit that i think
the purchase of that machine will be
fine
why don't you hold microsoft accountable
microsoft said series actually
performance microsoft said
series s is the 1440p 121st machine
empty problem since y'all excuse
me that's what the topic is here for you
so that we can address this that that's
not hush mouth
see that this is the ish i know it's not
in color i know i know
and i should address it but at the end
of the day you can't
get on someone's platform and say why
don't you address it
we're literally talking about why we may
be a little disappointed and frustrated
with this aspect that blows my mind when
people say
you gotta hold them accountable like
what are you not listening to
anyway yeah one other thing that
absolutely should be held accountable
more so than the machine
because this machine is well more than
capable right yeah
it's a matter of you need to put the
work in uh another thing that's
it's a side uh sort of issue but i think
it's funny
all this talk about it being like the
ultimate emulation machine or whatever
i think really works in its favor right
when you look at the amount of people
that bought psps
to just to just jailbreak that machine
right in the end right it messed up the
their ecosystem right
i don't think xbox has that problem
because the ecosystem since it's fluid
across all their consoles
it doesn't really matter right and and
from what i can tell right now
you can enable that that sort of uh
emulation stuff
without uh like voiding your warranty
meaning you could still use your machine
normally
um so you know again it's a side
conversation to be had but i think
in the long term you see sales of that
system
get a bump just from that absolutely
absolutely
narrative out and not stopping it yeah
you're not getting super trying to get
kicked let's talk about them
uh we have emery with the five dollar
super chat
people act like god of war ascension
didn't exist 343 on this next halo will
be fine
halo has to get two things perfect can
naughty dog do that
interesting okay then we have lucius
augustus with two
super chat or he runs at 4k 60 fps on
the series s
i was just about to address that lucious
don't you know
square bullets and we have squirrelly
two dollars that can't cure stupid
people god
i didn't say that yeah
like i said i know i'm i know the
majority titles that they've said
you know there's there are a lot of 120
frame games
on the ass i'm not trying to disrespect
little man i just was a little emotional
when i saw them
your destiny and i was like come on in
my opinion i'm not a dead but i'm like
damn i feel a little man could do that
but um owner yes
as a series s owner and you flexed all
of it
except why you have to flex like i don't
know what i'm talking about
he got big swallow okay
let me show you my back
you know that's that's highly
disrespectful yes somebody
just turned around
so as i see all this information coming
out first of all
the the demographic isn't 120 hertz okay
up to a hundred and hurt so that doesn't
mean every title is going to reach that
uh
that pinnacle also it says up to 4k
checkerboard of course yeah no but
it's it could do 4k but it's a 14 for
the machine
technically what you're going to get is
um 1080p
machine 64 50 frames per second yes you
know basically this is what they
they're trying to achieve 1440p 30
frames per second oh no no no
no that's 336. for the tl tcl dude 60
servers
talk to him isn't marketed to
the high end consumer the high consumer
is not worried about price he's not
worrying about
um anything but the best so when he
walks in the store and he says excuse me
um what is the best microsoft has to
offer somebody's not bringing him the
white box they're bringing him the black
box
okay so when somebody's being frugal and
they're coming in and they're trying to
game on a budget name
they want to achieve and they want to
still play along they're going to
definitely pick up the white box
not saying that white box isn't capable
but in these economic times right now
the white box is only viable
for a lot of people it was viable for me
right
okay in my bedroom i don't game that
much but if i choose to pick up my
controller and play
my ass right there is more than capable
at 60 frames per second
i'm not asking for it to hit 120 frames
in my bedroom
i'm trying to be competitive with little
men little man is doing exactly what
little man was purchased for
little man was purchased for that in
between time
you know a little that's true i'm
looking for my son to get a little man
but he know what he said to me
i will wait daddy i will wait x because
he likes to put physical games in his
joint i don't know where
he gets this from but um he likes to put
physical games in it because he likes to
go downstairs
pick up a disc and throw it inside
that's what still
to this day he still has his xbox i gave
him the um xbox one x
you know he had the regular one yeah and
he you know he
he loves that so that is marketed to
my son that is marketed to uh the
financially
uh strapped or the casually
the casual dudes there's a lot of casual
people
that you say 120 friends they're like
what the hell are you talking about
right
they don't know anything they don't know
4k the 120
they don't care they just want to get in
game and get going
so when when the performance is not
hitting for certain people
we have a box for you right right and
that box is the xbox one
x i mean the xbox series x right there
i'm glad they discontinued that act
but i understand your concerns no
there's not even a concern
it's more so you just don't like it i
see little man in the gym lifting that
like i see him like he just did gears he
just did
um what you call it um dirk is doing 120
like
i see him so i'm just like yo i don't i
don't
get those are people that got the good s
sdks
honestly believe that those people
that's pulling that out a little man
they know they know how to talk to
little man you know
people they got the good box to talk to
hey hey little man
what i want you to do this round is i
want you to spin left and move right
here i can do that you understand so
they talking the little man in his
language
i think the other dudes don't got the
proper sdks for i'll tell you i
guess i just what i just feel it's a
powerful machine i know we joke we call
it a little bit
i just feel it's a powerful machine and
i just don't want it to not get the
full attention that the series x is
getting from a
from a development kit standpoint from a
developer and it may very well
solve maybe right it may very well just
be the damn developer
getting either the tools and getting
more acclimated and how they can do
stuff and it's just me being impatient i
just don't want it because in my opinion
when i
see stuff like this for dirt ori rainbow
six siege you know
i'm seeing these games i'm like whoa i
wasn't expecting
120 in no fashion from them to be honest
and then when i see it so now i'm like
nah fam we got to keep this level of
consistency
going through if possible that's all i
was saying
or there shouldn't be any reason for
anybody to try to cap against
as you call it little man yeah when or
each of the
people were easy to pay 300 switch
factual
factuals there couldn't even be no
topics about it i mean anything
even in the category
i'm a fan a little bit i i like what he
tried to do out here and i just woke up
i'm gonna tell you this right now if
they give you a portable screen that
attaches a little more oh
man
you know that is a possibility yeah
and we shout out to i believe uh my boy
ty got travis from my gym we had one
last one he actually used to get those
consoles that you put in the suitcase
and you remember you had the lid with
the joint yeah i could totally see your
series
we're going to go more we got them we
got to get ready remember the time we
went to
pull out his xbox right there with the
screen yes
stop being coming up with these fly
gaming history stories sparking memories
anyway do i help your phone with right
outcome out of here oh in regards to the
recent departures of the two bioware
leads leaving the studio which bioware
franchise
in your opinion has the best
chance for success moving forward the
choices are a
the mass effect series b
dragon's age c
anthem or d stop it fan we all know
bioware is officially in the bushes from
this point going forward
those are the choices please rock the
point when it goes up
on ilp twitter lord k
mega from grg podcast
some of the best gaming history ever
crazy positive message long overdue to
unify these realms of the grg podcast
iop with
tremendous respect always appreciate you
what you do out here in the industry and
also the community
as well as get a chance to actually meet
you in person
e3's conventions moving and shaking
salute to the team
where can i find people find you what
you have going on sir all right man
really appreciate it man this was a lot
of fun man
um i got to definitely get you guys on
grg man for sure i got the time
hey no doubt um you catch me on twitter
at kmega4
uh on twitch um k-mega 405
uh fight night tonight so you know get
ready for that
it's gonna be fun a lot of trash talking
you know getting down
and that's and then of course i'll take
my l's there'll be people in there
that's going to go across my head but
it's still just fun you know for the
love for fighting
uh also the um my youtube channel uh k
mega 405 and of course the grg podcast
that comes on every friday night
i think uh we i i think we're going to
go back to our original time at eight
o'clock instead of seven
okay um and so that's probably what
we're just gonna we're gonna do on that
but it's
every friday night um and then you know
shout out to uh
the uh next podcast i do that every
thursday night with my boy xbox 448 and
the team over there
fred and all them uh and then yeah just
just everybody that's been a part of
this man thank you guys for having me on
man this is this was fantastic today
fantastic man
right long overdue brother love what you
do along with them also
love your fight love read it we get
people that love to fight games the way
we do it you still keeping that going
phil get get these fighting games on
these on this xbox man we need that
guilty gear strife we need
man we need that king of the fighters we
need it bro the new king of the fighters
yes we do
yes we need we need it we need it we
need it we need it
actually absolutely joy and then you get
your outro sir
we got emery with the five dollars which
had amd just released the full features
of rd and a2 so expect the series x
gdks to be updated to get better
performance ps5
is performing slightly better now okay
let's get amd all right let's get that
so i'm looking to find people find you
man rocking out yeah
first shout out to mega man we met mega
at e3 a couple years back it feels like
forever ago but man
mega is is that dude you see him bring
big smile on his face
give you a big hug it's always love like
uh
it's amazing to have people in the
community like that and just people that
you've just
spoken to a couple of times whether on
social media whatever when you meet them
and it and it's just like it's fan like
it's it's just it's just lovely that's a
beautiful thing
and i can say that about damning
everybody that we met at e3 you know
it's like you know you have this
relationship online whatever the case
may be you meet these people in person
it just
it just flows the same way megatron tim
dawg all of them yeah absolutely
right yeah 100 when i met colton his
wife man it was just yeah
it's fantastic out there yeah it's
fantastic so
as for me i will not be going to work
today because i owe
flames i owe flamish
an appearance on his podcast so check me
out on on the exes podcast
at 4 p.m eastern time on youtube flame
yeah double shift today flamish the
positive game i think i think clowns is
going to be on today
in a couple of days so come through and
check it out it's going to be a great
show
it's 4 p.m eastern time and then beyond
that oh yeah
i go back to my regular schedule this
week
lord king with the smoke in the jokes as
usual we're going to probably find you
what you got going on sir
first shout out to k mega and the team
uh
we all connected so and any man that
drives out to calabasas
we gotta respect caveman because bad
people say well come see us
definitely fronted on us um and you
definitely a real one so that for that
drive you definitely got my offer
i appreciate it man definitely 100 y'all
dudes came out there y'all was like yeah
i was like wow you know we hung out you
know
fan fest and uh for those that want to
see uh
k mega's uh skills in gaming yeah uh
him versus tim dawg a member of the
realm
that means you know like follow and
subscribe and also hit that join button
at the bottom
and you can see that video in the back
that i got because it's little things
that we record you know while we there
but that was something that was
definitely epic
because these dudes were talking hot
garbage to each other and i was
definitely
terry right was that bad
it was mattered it was right too this is
definitely football fanatics boy
two big boys out there getting it done
fast
it was fantastic and i'm glad i captured
it all right so for a lot of y'all
that's saying
yo king where that kos at you know i've
been trying to get this uh battle over
planets this geforces gotcha man this
eagle
what's going on king well king uh my
um media mod came in let me see if i can
lean that in there can y'all see that
all right so the media mod came in for
the gopro 9.
i said yeah we're going to put this on
we're going to get this working
i sat there and i shot the video and i
talked i was like yeah and i did it
at the end something going on with the
gopro 9.
damn uh exactly threw me straight into
the bushes damn
i said okay i'll figure it out and i'm
gonna figure this stuff out because
i have statues that's in the back and i
want you guys to see that so this is
what we're going to be doing with dolph
castle x
i'm trying to get the numbers up for
dolph castle x what i will be doing on
golf castle x's
i will be doing live unboxings so my
live unboxings i will also be recording
this so
when i do my kos you get the synopsis
the story and everything about the
statue
but you get the live you know unfiltered
unboxings no editing just you know you
just check it out see me unboxing
statues
um fridays at 9 00
pm you know uh i say it's a dcx youtube
channel so people know right dcx
yes go there you know join or
hit the subscribe button and uh
definitely uh check us out
9 p.m it's a little little off color so
you know
yeah they loose
stuff over there you know you definitely
have fun you can find me on twitter
kingdom tw your [ __ ] xbox
king david otw you can find on
playstation whenever i
activate this thing again because i
still haven't been able to log into my
playstation account
um this xbox 360 level 01.
maybe your name has something to do if
it continues
or man made me start from scratch but i
got at least two games over there that i
paid for
and i want i'm not doing like sovereign
and i'm not going to
let y'all erase my games like thanos
man shout out to gabriel by choice
following super chat great show guys i
just saw the k
mega everyone keep it gaming much love
to organize salute man
shout out to dan the man cunningham we
can't go a show without saying dan
you know but yeah man shout out to one
bad [ __ ] man he's the one that
that's my brother who hooked me up with
that series x man thank you
absolute pleasure man you already know
they haven't been around wrong overdue
had to make the call get my brother you
already know and um yeah man we got some
more fun shows lined up for the rest of
the year
um approaching soon a couple more and
then we'll go back to 1 p.m eastern
in the new year so we're almost
finishing up with 11 a.m
okay you know what i haven't reduced i
could have used 1 p.m today you can use
it today
but yeah
the love the love was tremendous man
love what you're doing hit those likes i
forgot attica told me if you hit the
likes he's going to give away a quote i
forgot damn it
but we will get that cold we'll get the
patrols everything next week right
so everything we'll get everything
straightened out look everybody enjoy
your sunday that's all i got anybody got
anything else if not
oh we got one more we got strong kingdom
king reset the ps5 and swipe the card by
the back
oh
[Laughter]
everybody enjoy your sunday we're out of
here peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
you